hey guys it's Eric here so before the
video starts I just want to do a quick
kind of explanation overview of what the
comodo boss challenge was so when you
watch the video you're not like entirely
confused of what was going on this was
an event run by chess comm and sponsored
by twitch and it featured streamers from
all over the world competing in teams
taking on comodo which is a chess engine
you can play on chess comm and Komodo
has varying levels of difficulty so the
format was that we start on level 1 and
we have to beat each level consecutively
and work our way up as high as possible
and there's 20 total levels of Komodo
and by the time you get to level I think
like 18 or 19 the rating is is well over
2500 I think level 20 of the rating is
3000 now there was a lot of money on the
line and I'll go ahead and just share
some links here which I'll link
everything in the video description one
is just kind of the overview of the
prizes there's different prizes for for
the regional between Europe and North
America there were also prizes for being
able to complete special challenges so
at the beginning of the video we were
going for the win with nine Queens which
is a cool five hundred dollars we were
also trying to go for a meat by castling
another cool five hundred dollars if you
watch the video you'll see if and what
we won and there is also a main
production a main broadcast of this
event on the twitch rivals twitch page
they had amazing kind of production and
commentary with Robert Haas and Danny
wrench here and and some other guy wave
punk I guess his name is so that's just
quick explanation I'll probably provide
some more information in the video
description one more thing before I
start the video Alexandre botas will be
doing a highlights reel of the stream if
you don't have three and a half hours to
watch this whole video
I highly recommend taking a look at her
channel I'll leave it again in the
description and shall she'll have a much
shorter highlights reel where you can
see the best moments from from this
event so without further ado enjoy
watching and I'll see you guys in the
next video I was so pumped I'm gonna
we're gonna beat up everyone we're gonna
beat up Komodo so badly that he's gonna
become sentient just so that he can it
just so his feelings are as well yeah
that's how bad we're gonna beat up cuz
yeah
Erik is so hot
that's kind with his moves to just wait
what's happening here I don't understand
so let's do komodo in the chat so chat
people get confusing they come in feel
free to help and you command Komodo or
command overview that's the practice run
[Music]
okay it's 2:30 it's 2:30 I'm here for
the announcement oh okay it began I'm
sorry alright it's wait it's taking a
long time to accept the challenge
yesterday as well because so many people
are playing it okay we're in okay I'm
gonna just try and win material quickly
yeah yeah I'm just done yeah Mike thanks
for the ones there are certain stages so
first we have to win material okay this
is a great this is great start winning
everything okay good
I'm traded off this Queen well if L
castling for it been GM Conti lost pawns
so we should still go for the double
focus on the game I'll let you know if
any of them do it I think Ben is going
for the castle no he can't castle
anymore so Ben can't get any more prizes
take your time take your time even Conti
can still do both okay is he close to
either he's not close to either so take
your time okay he can't do that
yes he cancelled it yes so he's the
closest to you okay but you're further
ahead you're much closer than anyone so
you can take your time to make sure
there's no cellmates okay he still has
to promote all the Queens he's promoted
none wait somebody said Ben one with
Castle II what I don't think so I think
they're tricking us just keep going keep
doing it okay right can you guys confirm
if you ignore chat they're tricking us
their training but they're tricking us
cuz I watched his game I watched his
game and he didn't do it
or did he oh shoot you're just going for
the Queen's shoot he did okay so just go
for the Queen sorry about that that's
good
Conte going for the Queen's as well so
just get nine Queens and we're good okay
we did it yes yes let them know in
discourse you guys please please please
please the nine Queens thank you okay
that's nice
yes so we should have finished it
amazing okay I'm in a challenge now
trying to get a mate as fast as possible
okay let me follow you yeah okay so we
all we need to do is now work our way up
that's okay
I do you want to resign and redo or yeah
just win all the material yeah exactly
[Music]
well it would wouldn't be a bonus stream
without that you know okay I made it
we're good
your turn to go on the next one
so level two right yes it doesn't really
matter how fast we do it probably it's
just whoever gets the furthest right cuz
multiple people are gonna get stuck at
the highest levels that's true
I'm sorry taking one moment here level
two it's alright alright yeah this is
just a matter of like winning material
yes I feel like we could do it until he
starts getting decent and then we could
start team working yeah maybe some
screens better than one nine Queens
challenge okay thank you so much
sixty-four hearts up in the discord I
think we got it earlier than other
people issues all right your turn level
two yeah yes if you're stuck in Thai
break it is with somebody who got there
faster okay that's good to know
yes um that was fast
alright keep clicking put some
challenges that play against computer if
there's a faster way that you found let
me know okay yeah I'll get mine set up
so I'll have to wait again he saw the
mate how could I keep trying to he
defended oh you're doing well just
develop like develop castle maybe HH 5h4
yeah
okay I could also beat him by playing
fast and see moves almost instantly
that's true
yeah I mean you can play a lot of like
just normal improving moves keep winning
material and simplify yeah
Bishop c6 or that's nice looking good he
is seeing my mates it's very confusing
the things this is actually what happens
like towards the end is they'll put up a
lot of like resistance like they'll find
the longest possible meet yeah so it
helps to promote or just take all the
material yeah enough to mates okay all
right and thanks Omer enigma for the
bits so now I'm playing it would be nice
to get that confirmed yeah I'm just
gonna go for the kill like look at these
pieces it's for Eric I'm thinking for
you I appreciate that I would like to
out sports that that job I'm just mating
in - okay your turn okay
level three can you check yeah can you
check on a discard to make sure that we
don't have to post it right away to
claim it and then I'll go for level
three yeah oh so we we did earn it it is
confirmed we got the nine quick strategy
so we won $500 250 I'm sorry that's too
much for what it is okay yes the
computer knows how to spot me out of my
face
all men and another team in our section
tried the bishop night mates not
realizing that's not an eligible price
yeah we're not putting in the work he's
not that rose ever was I guess it feels
bad to be unprepared hey sorry he's
taking his sweet sweet time just be
patient like figure out how to mate when
the rook I'm just gonna give an overview
for the chat to might be confused our
goal is to reach the highest level of
Komodo within three and a half hours
there's 20 levels and we're competing
against four or actually just three
other teams in our array dang okay very
nice I'll start a game so we're already
on level four and the first levels are
very easy at least win a prize this is
the Moto floor yes so I'm gonna get my
challenge ready as well as you've been
doing okay great
drink it the night challenge I'm not
sure we're gonna have to check in on
that oh you had reported it okay awesome
awesome yeah no I can't say we're losers
now we've already won something ha
that's not bad from 250 bucks in like
five minutes
no I can't complain and not hopefully
okay we're gonna see a ladder mates get
ready for it the waiting move another
waiting move there we go
okay nice okay I'm going
I think I'm just gonna play normal and
blitz it out Ben is still on level three
and we're on level R on level four this
Bend is an old slow man you should see
how he rose I'm not gonna insult me or
insult him because he says amazing they
said such nice things about me you can
insult him all you want yeah we already
have a rivalry so I have to keep up the
drama keeping up with the Benjamin's
understand that I mean if they attack
you have to counter-attack
exactly otherwise they'll think we're
weak exactly
I like your position
yeah of course is gonna find the longest
mate just bring your Queen to d2 so now
our level 5 that's amazing both his
sisters coming in stealing some cash
solid never insult the comedian that's
true my bro look I'm just resting back
it's friendly it's actually friendly
okay I've just converted or simplified
into an end game it's gonna take a
little bit of work okay get rid of the
Knights his Knights are tricky we're
doing by just bulleting it out yeah no I
I'm so thankful you're my teammate cuz
you're like you're a bullets
genius I sometimes enjoy your wine thank
you again for the raid okay nice I'm in
you're next okay I are you drinking
coffee I'm drinking a vanilla latte
that's great I need the company sorry I
was talking to Komodo and I said what
are you doing
that's okay so this is five so next one
will be six hopefully mm-hmm that's the
free rook okay I'll just keep developing
for now maybe cc5 g5 yeah okay so I can
get the nice rookie so how can I just
push up for yes I think so that's that's
okay you know what resins start a new
game this is sure because you're you're
gonna lose you're going to be down at
rook you have to abort and rematches as
the other color okay so this might be
the quickest way to do it actually
sorry about that
I'll try and help out too okay team's
candy nice
I just develop natural moves oh you can
rotate or it takes you two yeah I think
just keep developing okay it's being
terrible with opening principles and
once you have more pieces developed one
piece yeah Bishop c5 attack f2 okay you
just win that h6 pawn and then trade
everything they're very nice I just take
everything yeah good to go Oh Brooke g2
and your meeting yeah yeah f2 very yes
okay you're German
so we're at six Fricks you're yeah well
yeah I know guys I must let that one but
the whole point is I was trying to go as
fast as possible because speed matters
too and it's hard to play accurate when
you play well unless you're Eric Rosen
and you're a beast
I tried it's gonna get tough though it
is gonna get tough it's already kind of
playing normal chess it's still playing
terribly but hasn't hung anything yet
okay Ben is on Komodo five kanji is on
Komodo four planet chess club is on four
so we are we're doing very well okay
very good thank very well because if we
get to the hardest highest level fastest
then we're gonna win right it's about
speed yeah exactly so we just want to
get there fast because at some point is
gonna get so hard that we can't even
beat it but if we were the first ones to
get there we still win thank you so much
thank you so much okay I'm just going to
simplify yeah this is this is a one in
game you could do this in your sleep I
know you can't it's not exactly meted oh
well now I feel like I'm in good company
so thank you for sure
Matt Brio thank you so much for the 14
months also map real I have the computer
report from yesterday's thanks again for
helping that Brielle has helped me
helping me fix front of my computer
issues it's very much appreciated you
got this it's taking a while but okay
we'll have another ladder mate that's
fine okay your turn okay just got the
steak on this is where we start being
calm be accurate me calm if I'm calm
that's a bad sign I need the intensity
in my life alright at least for me I'll
be calm you can be intense yes er norm
I like your open files what is this
computer doing he's 88 yeah
[Music]
fifty-two just started invading yeah
throw punches
take me to maybe yeah okay let's just
take some fun let's try to see if
there's anything better not so close to
mates but I know it's not it's not gonna
fall for like an easy mates yeah okay
don't take on c3 because you have to
watch out for counter play maybe Queen
oops okay
restart that's okay okay now the boat s
gambit or boats has sacrifice that was
brain fart okay okay so now just just
play simple exchange pieces yeah yeah I
agree
nothing too fancy okay do what it wants
to do I will take check take oops that's
okay
Keeney seven yeah just take pawns push
the eight that a pawn is your is how
you're gonna win yeah like be six take
upon okay you can start pushing put the
book back on a two and play or a one
even the bishop should be on d4 so
Bishop c3 to d4 Oh or Queen nice okay
I'll let you finish go I have to get
ready this is sick so next one b7
me good
can I just take the phone I know you
lose your queen yeah I was like okay
I'll just do another check then yes and
raka fit I think though I was trying to
see if that was me
I mean you can play like Queen d6 just
quiet move and then yeah and then b5 and
rook b8 and take Bishop c3 okay okay
level seven keep playing a London it's a
speed thing so we have to try to be fast
so we are looking for these fastest
mates that's what we're trying to do in
case you guys are curious Ben is on
level six okay kanji is on level six
planet Chess Club I can't even tell what
level they're on they're on level six
okay okay I'm just simplifying
everything nice yeah so it seems like
simplifying internet and game is the
best way to beat these low levels huh
yeah I have challenge ready thank you
guys so much for helping okay your turn
wow that was seven gave me all its
pieces you're right okay I'm just gonna
play like I would take a game seriously
and then try to as soon as he drops a
piece we're chillin simple chess may be
rook t4
okay what about that's nice for now rook
D 458 or Bishop f5 now yeah yeah okay
double up rooks
think I can take give me my work over
that's all the tricky
he didn't repeat ok I put my work back
where it belongs
here's a free pond I said mine ponds are
valuable ponds are very valuable
okay okay watch out for meats yep Queen
sea for a rook okay that's good 257 yeah
now I will queen bee for the queen trade
from male oh yeah hold on this would be
five maybe or Bishop d4 it's still gonna
take a little bit work because obstacle
our bishops yeah just a little I thought
it was you just bring your king all the
way in nice yep this is take the g3 pawn
yeah I'll take everything I'll just
we'll be on level 8 next yep okay
okay okay Jenny good okay level it's you
I was playing this line last night
against its each six is weird know it
completely crumbles in this line oh okay
in the London system in the longest
great well I'm playing as black so I
guess it doesn't matter but I'm glad you
know still me is that really you know I
actually paid someone to take my place
okay does didn't fix his board so I
can't tell what level he's on Conti is
still on six Chess Club is still on six
does anyone know what level Ben is on we
are kicking so much ass good good good
he's on level six or seven okay okay
your turn Oh aggressive dragon with no
respect for his King side position
whatsoever C six solid yeah yeah and
then take maybe Queen g7 go for like h5
just go for the posture attack h5h for
even King f8 yeah oh can you uh I think
there's mate rook takes h4 and the Queen
G for Queen f3 very good yes yeah and
then just watch out for counter play
like take it slow I have to put my king
somewhere on the side so do I want to do
King
or king of seven you gotta play King g8
because other lines don't work
no probably resign she's defending its
defending its so you could let me try
that again
I'm gonna try to play a version of
London with black I like it okay your
night belongs on d6 at least one of the
Nights yeah Queen f6 and then rook f3 oh
okay that's annoying
yeah I'll help a bit closer this time
okay if I get nervous
sure okay 98 good luck no this is a
great line this is great whites
overextending Bishop f5 yeah take
another pawn Knight f6 just developed
castle watch out for Queen b5 check okay
this is fine take on d5 this is all
great knight c6 or it takes okay
it's fine okay now Queen d6 and rook to
yet yeah
Oh Knight d4 is almost wing material
almost and then maybe King King down yes
oh wait wait slow down slow down
an f3 is made into right and or no king
g1 and then Queen d1 now we take it slow
yes so f5 I allow for checks rook t6 you
can also maybe win material
like you could I can move the night as
well just put on g5 and then bring more
pieces maybe Knight d4 then you'll have
access to f5 and c2 okay so night c2 and
they'd see - King F for all right Queen
c1 or rookie six yeah I like Queen c1
cuz you might win the Queen oh no you
don't win the Queen that's okay this is
tricky now maybe rook t5 like rook lifts
obviously no rook rook about five
threatening Queen off for ya I need
offense and no maybe five I like e5 yeah
yeah maybe 94 oh no sorry sorry not 94
sorry okay that's tricky I should get my
queen okay I could push no e4 he's just
gonna take g5 he's gonna take with a
knight
I don't know if that means maybe just
rook d8 see what it does okay that's a
decent sign what about rook d4 and then
Queen afore is that me I don't think it
is that's very close King h3 they put
the King on g7 first okay now you have
some opportunity or do you have sevens
attacked maybe I should just take the
knight here
yeah I take the knight and then the go
is gonna block or not from this f-7s
hanging rock d4 and then you takes on f7
you're right okay you might have to
start another game I don't see your
clear path here oh wait oh that's my
mates that's okay
restart restart okay okay
I will play more slowly and then oh yeah
because we had crushing advantage it's
just a matter of staying calm do a
French each six yeah each six should be
fine
Queen right you know the structure
better than me but maybe Queen b6 at
some points yep ninety-four I like there
should be seven rook c8 a five nice yeah
why not yeah and then maybe rook c8 let
him take on b6 yeah okay
ooh can you win them oh you can't wait
now now we think cuz I think you're
winning material after Queen takes b5
and d4 and you travel or wait no you
don't almost okay well maybe you should
retreat my bishop now and now Bishop g2
is almost trapping the rook you can go
to g1 maybe just king e7 and rook okay
try to trade off mm-hmm this pawn is
weak now yeah the point is thank you for
the two months okay castle and then if
he takes or I could just play okay I'm
gonna try to get in it's not taking the
pawn that's good maybe now go and I see
five and yeah the rook 757 yeah hey and
then Knight 94-94 mm-hmm hey maybe just
rook d7 and win the pawn on e5 take
sorry Knight be so I could take it after
you okay that's nice I like that
and I'm Poisson very nice okay no I kind
of like pushing pushing looks fine
um probably rook t2 I get the rook on
the second drink defend the pond or rook
c3 here Brooke c3 I like to yeah that's
probably stronger than rook to you - I
don't know then you can play like 94 you
have to just attack the rook with your
knight yes easier said than done
yeah maybe just 94 here okay three first
just take another nice yeah that's just
mildly annoying a knight in the center
okay he's gonna win the pawn Row 3 rook
b3 is nice I believe and now Brooks yeah
good very good
still gotta like stay focused this pawn
is a little bit annoying yeah very good
I like it and probably take twice take
twice and then the Knights of it over
words and now you can take on d5 okay
let's find two King g6 and now you can
start running the very good probably
just get rid of the Knights like okay
well you could have almost taken my room
that's okay just don't sell me I think I
must messed up already
that's annoying just like I'm gonna get
it ready and then all be here okay okay
somehow I messed up but it messed up
even more so that's that's a good thing
that's a very good thing you're very
close to a meeting yeah just when all
the material yeah okay you're you're
winning all the material this is fast
okay okay just get rid of stuff
apparently Levien not car at level 7 so
that makes me feel better that's good
of course naka is gonna beat the final
boss so actually I have Eric Rosen
Magnus Slayer on my team so I think if
you can slay Magnus you can slay little
old Komodo
yeah I'm not afraid does this mean oh
that's not me don't give me too much
confidence right right okay that's me
you're good to go
level 9 yep okay I'm gonna play things
that I know a little better
oh he would go into this line okay
actually simplifications fine cuz it's
gonna blender some pawns and then you'll
you'll be okay
yeah like take a pawn no trade
everything down you can take on c3 even
[Music]
okay I'm gonna play rook d8 and maybe
rip d3 I like rook teeth yeah rook t3
looks good and then you win the c3 point
I can protect the pond King f8 rook
takes c3 threatens rook C 100 your rooks
trapped restart okay you had a good
position it was just a matter of slowing
down yeah yeah okay I'll remind myself
to slow down
we're mean we're only 35 minutes in so
we have like almost three hours left
yes so once I get an advantage I'll slow
down or I could just look out now um he
doesn't he does respect bishops that's
cool
I'm thinking like rook e8 sandy for
Knight b6 I'm thinking d5 I get this
good French structure more space you're
not enough six defense
oh yes might be five in the end yeah um
because his knight will be pinned okay
Knight Queen e7 I like it okay
seven let's not give no they Bishop e6
and rook a c8 okay I'll take sure or
leave it what about rookie okay I like
that
oh can you in the night maybe Queen
Queen before like slow and steady Queen
before looks good
the counter-attack 9595 yep okay okay
now take the knight now trade Queens and
III simplify don't give it tricks hmm
control chess maybe double on the C file
yeah okay
move the Knights and just Rick see -
yeah I'm gonna trade now I'm try and win
this Queen side pawns like rook c3 or
okay - okay - I like you just want to
make another Queen yeah okay this is
still winning you just want to get rid
of that Knights probably okay just push
the a pawn yep and then the H pawn
spread them thin
okay and then for Quinn the Knights and
don't stalemate be careful be careful
Knight d4 yeah
Queenie to Knight f3 yep okay okay very
good
so Komodo 10 okay so this is where
things start getting a little bit more
serious I'm gonna still play London
solid opening he was very nervous I know
there's the same I'm in a rush so take
your time and I think I've been doing
the opposite of that mm-hm
it's okay we're still in very good shape
yes okay it's just getting brutal eyes
on the Kings side guys where's Benjamin
where's Ben sign gold out check you guys
no please let us know I'm looking for
mates here same level okay um no
thinking take six work off 17-year takes
yeah gonna be up material you could just
you could probably simplify this I just
don't want to lose a knight in the end I
take if you take the bishop rook takes
rook takes King takes and then move your
knight and you're up to pause um yeah
that's one way to go I'm looking at
Bishop takes f6 and then somehow winning
ok I'll be up to pawns in either line
yeah you're gonna be good in both lines
um okay I'll just convert the sending
alright 3 always play off three okay
it's amazing how it defended that attack
yeah but still find
you have two connected passers you have
connected passers he just he doesn't
even really do the scariest lines and
end you know okay oh I'm gonna get ready
I get ready
okay you're good to go okay if you don't
know what this is do command comodo I'm
gonna play a safer line closed positions
I think are easier so we're 40 minutes
in on level 10 lots of time yep
interesting I like this opening choice
because if you get some structure where
it's very positional right I can take
the bishop here yes I need to make sure
you can't sack on the Kings side okay so
very fine so far very controlled at some
point it'll give you a pawn hopefully
yep probably maneuver the knight to c6
okay and it's gonna play waiting move so
you have a lot of time here so maybe
before I like it bishop basics yeah
b3 keep improving starting to sweat I
want to get my knight on e4 pawn takes
pawn probably open the long diagonally
that's true I take with the bishop do I
check oh there's Queen e8 actually which
is more annoying so I could just play
Queen b8 okay now he's going for
something else thinking at some point
Bishop a3 it doesn't quite work
immediately yeah I would say play King
f8 King f8 okay Bishop b4 where's my
bishop going
on the end honestly you might want to
you might want to trade queens and then
the ending should be winning with your
your king will get to the Queen side my
king is right so you could maybe
maneuver the bishop from c4 it's a
better square like like see to defend
the pawn and then control the long
diagonal I like that
okay let me offer a queen Jade no he
doesn't want it yes he knows that
endgame is worse
I think your king should be on each
seven yeah maybe f8 try to trade yeah
the King okay that's fine as b2 is very
weak yeah maybe a bishop g6 first Bishop
g6 protect everything yeah and then try
and invade
wait okay Queen a for trying to
calculate bending Bishop before known
attack the knight okay actually Queen c4
looks good here Quincy for I like nice
no Queen c2 very good there's a d3 case
yeah I can't take though I can play
Bishop c4 though you know what you could
do like movies and maneuvering a king to
a4 are you sure bishop or a Bishop c4
yeah Bishop c4 is nice yeah actually
yeah that's much much better
no he's just a void perpetual a g6 it
gets a little bit weird
yeah g6 and now King g8 yeah and then
King
I mean I can play queen a3 in blocks
though I like it yeah Queen a3 very good
good find Queen I think and now put the
coin on c8 yet are pushing points just C
3 C 2 easy one just take it yeah okay
okay okay I'm getting ready yep
also shout-out to the twitch rivals who
are I think watching our stream right
now all right we did it
we're excited I'm excited
alright so it's actually playing like
reasonable kind of I'm not getting
anything immediate but I'm just trying
to keep the solid position yeah
okay now the pawns are weak upon
Benjamin Feingold Conte and planet Chess
Club a car who lost at ten he's because
he's trying to play sighs so give him
some credit you know get it thanks no
i'm cadry tagalog thanks so much for the
hype you guys I appreciate the hype it's
keeping us energized as well I'll pay
attention as well yeah it's this is
tougher now I'm losing the exchange kind
of maybe not no okay it's all about the
pawn promoting right now put it on a
seven and then I try my best so we're
gonna drop see - okay yeah I guess we
have what about Queen f3 here no cuz he
pushes s5 no that's actually a very good
you don't play Queen a5 though I think I
should double hooks I know play rugby
one and then
knock we have three mm-hmm is rook b8
rook b8 I want Oh rook takes off seven
maybe Brooke takes off seven oh never
mind okay
sorry that was bad play computer it's
Komodo loving right yep all right I'm
gonna play a London opening again we'll
play this line London is yeah it keeps
walking into this line which is just bad
for black but I have to punish it let's
play Knight d4 first f3 and now thank
you for reading with a party of eight I
really appreciate it I hope you're
having a good time with these twitch
boss rivals I'm so close to winning here
let's play this move came off a piece
kind of Srila was hanging Queen
everybody is judging people cuz we're
trying to do it fast it's okay um it's
playing really annoying chess but I'm
trying to consolidate okay um let's play
this move Oh
so yeah my bricks attacked I might just
take like I'm not material already
you're right oh no I can take off seven
if I want with the rook okay oh he's
starting to mess up yeah well I was just
playing very strange moves but I'm
trying to stay focused your
notifications but not seeing anything I
don't know what happened if you just did
something and I missed your notification
please let me know because I don't see
anything in the chat but I heard
something
oh it's from hosting and reading got it
Pharaoh's will welcome and thank you so
much 64 hearts Allah I just thank
cinetic okay Oh common on the verge of
winning it's still okay I should be very
easy let's win the Queen and then try
and win the bishop good okay there we go
okay I think I'm sorry guys my bed all
right this is looking great
simplification for the win
okay I'm gonna be ready okay okay I was
ready before now I'm not but I have it
watch this mates that was gorgeous
okay thank you let's see it's gonna keep
playing these French lines okay that's a
final thing yep I don't do you think
it's good at end games g6 and h5 would
be nice yeah okay I'll do that as well
yeah just rook c8 probably rook c8 b5
yeah again it's one of these positional
games maybe now Knight b8 to c6 chop the
rook a5 Bishop Bishop a6 yeah try and
trade off the dishes before I like yeah
getting quitter 7 really annoying bishop
his name is gonna get an annoying
placement but it was worth it
that's okay Queen b5 I like but then you
push a 4 with temple what about Queen b6
that's also fine I think what you want
to do is just Castle yeah and then oh he
can't because I take your take with
check and then you win d4 okay no maybe
rook c7 yep the whole idea you want to
like get some open file maybe even play
b3 like sack the pawn and open
a file or rook c8 and pretend prepared a
second India but that's also fine I like
that keep it simple okay yeah probably
just take very good yeah
Queen c4 you have to you have to be
careful though cuz this end game
actually don't know the kings very close
oh this actually doesn't issue so g5 you
know you can do maybe at six I'd
probably start with f6 okay and then g5
I was looking at and now you take the
pawn on e5 stopping stopping King g4
very important no no he can't take your
pawn
no now it still takes work probably h4
to prevent white from playing h4 now you
run with a pawn very good yeah honestly
like we can now calculate the at least a
weaker computer and King pawn endings
like especially if it's playing
automatic moves it's not as a very high
death it has a hard time like even
calculating some simple on race yeah
yeah that's good let me get ready okay
so we're on Komodo twelve right yeah
yeah you have to give support to the
sibling who's struggling a little you
should see the way she rosin yep I wish
I have emotional support I'm here for
you okay I appreciate this there we go
let's play castle Queen so I'm gonna go
for an attack this game I like my h-file
play f4 and try and get in it's kind of
annoying
twelve so we want to stack on the h-file
at some point or very possibly um g4 is
an idea mm-hmm I'm looking for like the
the breakthrough idea what if g4 and you
can take back with the Queen I like that
let's bring the knight to helps defend I
think I can take this yeah that looks
like actually in compensation and now
after g4 what does he do he takes it he
takes some plays Knight f5 unfortunately
I mean it's still probably good but I'm
gonna play rook okay
blunder vault if you're curious what's
going on there you go here's an
explanation do command Komodo
I got you foreign I don't know how good
it is so I oh I can't man on each seven
I might resign let's be tricky though
yeah I resign okay that's my don't don't
worry about it computer leading the
division by the way awesome so I checked
on Ben he's still in level 11 Conte's on
level 9 planet chess club's on level 11
we're doing great
I'll take it slow c4 oh yeah it's being
greedy computers are always greedy they
love pawn grabbing oh very nice okay
honestly I'm if it's a bad opening I'm
gonna resign and then yeah aborts I'll
have to be white black yeah is this a
team link yeah so we're on the same team
he plays with white I play with black
yeah I know it's annoying to rematch it
just puts on the wrong okay okay okay I
sent the challenge it's waiting to
accept taking a moment there we go
okay another London opening oh it's
doing something different Oh
while this line this line is interesting
I think I can take there and do this and
that save the night probably Wow
g5 so it plays really well aggressively
it seems like right because he didn't
calculate you know this is really
annoying okay it's not taking the draw
thankfully problem is I'm losing my
night thank you so much great job so far
you appreciate it
okay getting spanking I don't know it if
I know sometimes it's easier to think on
your own so if I ever I'm explaining and
you need to do that just let me know oh
yeah no worries I'm in an end game but
I'm like down a couple pawns I think
yeah he doesn't value pawns ISM as much
that's true so that's okay hedgehogs
thanks for gifting to chess rook a1 can
we maybe get a 6 or your knight get
strong put the King on doesn't work to
take that's difficult oh okay okay
let's go again oh wait let me send a
manual challenge computer yeah um you
know what he might not be good against a
reti like Knight of 3G three systems
yeah honestly I'm just waiting until it
falls in to my London prep because it
cycles through a few different openings
yeah and there's there's one line that
it sometimes walks into like this line
yeah here we go here we go yes I have
this against level nine this is probably
in your opening traps YouTube video
welcome thanks for joining in on the fun
yeah as it keeps walking into this but
now okay this is tricky because I want
to take on c6 6 with the bishop and then
playing Knight I can take on c6 with all
three pieces it's just a question
the g2 hanging okay so you're trying to
ignite takes c6 screen takes you yeah
you're even pawn takes b5 I think I'm
gonna tick or I also have Queen a for
Queen a4 could be very strong Queen
takes g2 and then I'm like rook f1 even
just look like one a4 okay I like it I
like it it's bold then I take okay let's
play rock f1 the promise pawn takes b5
it seems so close so what about Bishop
takes pawn takes Knight takes and then
you have oh he has 97 yeah ninety-seven
happens in the end of most variations I
could even take on e6 with the bishop
yeah you could take on a six and then
Queen trade if guy will take on a six
and then Wow snow takes maybe night
Knight takes no I could take six yeah
okay I'll be down upon unfortunately not
she's gonna win a - most likely mm-hmm
let's play Bishop Bishop d6 is actually
interesting okay does that work before I
like let's try you for very nice okay
now we're gonna have to miners for the
yeah the rook the problem is this is
still tricky to convert letting us know
but good thing we're not in the same
division SD card so we could win our
division and I would be awesome Andrea
just got to nine go little Sisko okay
now I just have to win pawns and the the
king will be out of play okay so this is
a this should be an easy win or is there
a better way to do it yeah I'm trying to
think there's maybe seven there's 96
yeah you're protecting a rookie - so
you're not really in danger maybe
Congrats
Chuck looking at rook c5 or just rookie
5 even yeah I think rookie 5 rookie 7
actually actually 96 might be like
strongest 96 sort of 96 and then might
be five very far away I was looking for
some like meaning idea about it but okay
I think I'm gonna win the f7 pawn in the
slide or not if you check you place King
b6 okay but at least the King's far away
I've Knight c3 Chuck or Knight c3
attacking the rook and then he checks on
a1 and he takes your rook ah maybe
Knight f d4 and then threatening rooks
he says I like it I like it bringing in
offering a draw that's playing mind
tricks I don't think it calculates that
well I think if we can grab one more
pawn we can expect I'm just trying to be
solid and at some point grab a pawn yeah
just careful not to move too fast and in
blunder yeah and maybe you don't blender
but h5 rook each six we don't want to be
left you're right with just one pond
yeah the Knights are a little bit clumsy
now um what about you bring your king to
h6 maybe pick on b4 like rook f4 protect
the night and then bring your king I
like that's very good yeah let's
maneuver this night somewhere happier
maybe night Knight g3
anonymous thank you so much for gifting
20 subs I don't know who you are
but I really appreciate it thank you so
much thank you
oh this is getting nice this is getting
very nice and you collect the paws you
did it you did it genius
I'm okay I'm still trying let's rook
it's annoying but I just don't want to
lose both pawns that's the key okay I'm
just gonna get rid of that okay okay
yeah finally Papa botas remembered about
his daughter okay
I'm going back to my positional chest
closed positions
okay he's playing a new line we're
getting to the point where like we
wanted to like be slow and steady but
this is nice I like what you're doing
the same structure I'm gonna play the
simplifying line here okay so I just
keep my bishop that's okay I just look
we inside actually here we're trying to
keep the pressure on what do you think
is or rook c8 I like rook c8 I like it I
mean you could even Castle kingside but
yeah a five a five bishop basics like
same ideas or before is nice too
yeah Queen T probably night tix get the
night looks very very good
now we slowed okay okay this is very
nice-looking okay and now Queenie's wait
wait just make sure is it's made right
wink when a five houses or queen bee two
will come all right
okay so queen bee - but then
put the knight on e4 94 threatening I
see three very good okay oh another
defense maybe it's still 94 to c3 just
make sure 94 that looks really annoying
now Knight c3 yep okay so now the
Queen's completely you might just want
to win the Queen like you can play Queen
b6 and rookie to Queen b6 and rook a -
yeah okay just just win the Queen yeah
and then castle bring the other rook in
might see get back this is great you can
still take it slowly all right I've been
eat d4 looks great
I like t4 unleash the bishop now Bishop
Bishop a4 trade trade the bishops and we
can see - I honestly I think it's mating
after Queen's he 5 and then Queen's
queen c3 rook a it's over that's very
very good
earlier no that was great sorry I have
to challenge it's not expecting to win
that quickly so we're on 13 I'll be
White's will have another London opening
you know what's interesting with alpha 0
when it was testing out the French they
had these charts for how much it liked
openings and that was its favorite for a
while oh wow
but then then it fell out of favor okay
I'm liking the opening is walking into
some preparation again gonna put the
bishop there and then g4 should win a
piece erik has very night my dad is
complement to you okay this is well
thank you mr. Cortes so okay so I'm just
trading I'm up a piece already
okay well simplify a little bit ooh
let's let's - probably be fun and for
being here thanks copy okay I'm going
all out like assaults good night before
doesn't do anything I'm gonna take the
pawn
and then take the other pond and then
it's going to defend with work at 6:00
why did the French fall out of favor
with alpha I'm not sure but it's good to
know that was popular for a while so it
seems like it'll be good against until
maybe it gets like 2,400 come on okay
now I still have to be a little bit
careful yes I agree
rooks pin let's all play Queen c2 okay
and then we'll trade I could take with
let's take with Queen I'll just keep it
simple
yeah simple it's worked until now and
you're very good at end games so thank
you okay
oh nice that's a pun I'm going for I was
going for mate with Knight f6 but oh
okay this'll work to f4 f5 honestly I'm
just gonna train like easy okay please
automatically so this is great okay okay
get ready yeah okay awesome
I'm here to waste no time okay sweet I'm
in very nice let's go French again all
right just keep it up it's gonna get
like slightly harder each level but I
realize that he's already canceled the
other way which is kind of annoying
he should trade like that that's kind of
weird
I need to get my bishop out yeah I like
you're just doing the same thing watch
out for it
probably g-cells okay be for cuz then I
can trade off my LightSquared bishop
mm-hmm whenever I want I can Knight
takes d4 Oh Rick c8 looks annoying
Brooke see it yeah okay you might want
to put the King on g7 and connect the
rooks I should probably get rid of the
knight first
oh you're saying king e7 should I do
right now
I was thinking King f8 to gf
my my my bishop was gonna be useless
soon okay 97 is a free night so I'm not
gonna do that
maybe rook c7 okay yeah rook c7 I like
rook double it up double it up and you
still camp I don't think you can play 97
but you want to maybe I could play how
can i Rima new ver my Knights
oh you know what you can do you can play
Queen b7 and Knight b6 nice I like it
okay and now nightly 7 probably take
with Brooke yeah yeah maybe night c4 now
take with pawn very good night d5 very
annoying to deal with Queen B 5 yeah
just improving moves Queen a4 um he has
b3 yeah maybe not honestly I think your
night belongs on f5 and Europe belongs
in d7 to attack the D pawn but I mean
your knight on d5 Pleasants okay I'm
gonna play Queen d5 first I like it
oh he's gonna get 94 and 96 but it's not
fast enough because I could play in
Queen d5 and rook d7 and then 96 and you
know I think you can do is play Queen d6
and Knight f5 quick Queen where Queen d5
and Knight f5 Queen do you found another
5
oh yeah just attack the g4 i like that
okay can I trade oh oh there's my queen
b5 only move or Quincy 6 - yeah Quincy 6
is also an option
I like Queen B 5 ok ok so let's see I'm
sorry I think your book wants to be on
d8 and rip c2 is a sign that it's not
doing anything
right Oh g4 okay now I can move my
knight to e7
yeah u7 you'll have Knight d5 I'm
thinking rook d8 first pressure the
point and now Knight seasick you just
want to make sure you're not getting
mated but knight c6 looks nice
Queen c6 is also annoying 96 because
you're threatening both pawns okay for
it's a very good I like it with a rook
right yes okay he's just trying to make
things messy it's still complicated
though it is complicated I think you can
you can probably take on g5 okay we just
have to calculate concretely yeah
because maybe we don't need to take any
pawns if I could play King h8 after G
takes h6 yeah you can also take before
she takes h6 King h8 and then II five
his name
tasty fourth yeah I was thinking Knight
takes e5 to with idea of Knight takes f3
but your line might be simpler
a truck takes d4 I like should we try it
yeah there's no 98 ideas okay yeah go
for it okay just be very very careful
Oh is he gonna take on g6 but then you
take back with pawn yes and he has no
checks okay and I can always protect the
g6 pawn with my knight yeah so he's
finding a mate in one
yeah this is very good sign now Queen
Queen takes probably Queen takes e5 c4
but then I can take the knight and he
takes you even have like yeah you have
attack against the king - yeah and when
you get the chance you want to play a
two right maybe even right now yeah nice
um okay
I can I can almost take the knight
yeah you want to be careful
I'm take it slow and steady thinking
like rook t1 ideas at some point yeah
I'm thinking about maybe 94 or 97 to
just be safe for now 97 is a very
controlled move I like that okay now
still be careful the Queen Queen is
short on squares actually yeah so Queen
c7 is an option
Queen B 8 at least attack that beachy
well the good thing is he can't bring
his Queen because we promote so we
should be that scared
I think Queen b8 is good yeah Queen B
it's fine it's defending from behind
Queen b3 and threatening rook t1 and if
he checks I come up and then he plays
Knight f6 or I could block you know what
you can do you can take the knight and
then play Queen b6 check and win the row
even better okay just don't get mated oh
that was a great move I think honestly I
think you have to play rook e5 also your
because he can then take the rook with a
pawn okay and now you Queen your long
time but you have to do this to second
comments I'm sorry okay Oh genius
defense okay try again we're doing very
well that was tricky towards the end
there yeah it's okay with my French I
could refresh and get him into French
that's okay just play
do you play Queens gambit declined do
her not really but I mean it's just a
matter of getting some positional game
yeah
simplify at some point it'll hang
material b6 probably Bishop Bishop takes
off three first six probably queen c8
just be safe okay we don't want to have
to deal with its calculation so II five
at some point but not yet yeah just I
want 96 for now I was thinking Knight d7
rook t89 f8 to g6
like Spanish night walk but he's gonna
get you five it may be 96 now or okay
this is still looking okay like 95 yeah
okay night night effect good you'll
you'll have that Foursquare mm-hmm like
night g6 right away night h4 allows
night h4 is it too risky I don't think
it's I want to kick off his Bishop what
about a six or four now but then he's
gonna push a five
I was thinking b6 queen b7 just slow
improvements okay yeah very slow play
here
c5 at some point you want to play see if
I maybe Brooke AC eighth first yeah wow
what is it doing
I don't like this take sticks okay
no you we have to take right yeah take
it see what it does I think h8
yeah can you change if I take everything
the problem is route 66 right try King
h8 though and then take back on g6 gonna
go yeah I mean you're up the exchanges
for like a bunch of constants yeah fine
let's try it
rook f8 yeah honestly I think you should
quickly restart hmm I think you should
restart you could try maybe Queen d5 and
see let me just see what happens
and then if you could actually trade
Queens and get some endgame there'd
still be some chance chance or just get
out of it yeah maybe maybe restart yeah
let's talk okay so we're just over an
hour in we're hour and 15 minutes in so
we still have lots of time yep depends
if we're faster than Ben is still in 12
okay that's good news okay I'm gonna
play going back to the lines I know that
I'm familiar with
okay very good yes stay with your
comfort zone yeah b6 and because it's d4
square is amazing yeah it is I don't
know cuz I need to protect first there
you have it which point I wanna take
with I feel like the e pawn yeah you
pawn chain 9 h5 maybe not yet I want to
bring my rook into play do I want to do
rook e8 I think your night belongs on e5
yeah Rick d8 push f4 yeah but it's a
good position like we should like stay
calm
rook e8 ideas of d3 yeah where should I
put my knight back is my question I
might want to get it to d6 I could push
at 5 it looks weird on the knight f7
mm-hmm yeah I don't know if you want to
block in the bishop though okay well
just keep putting pressure on the pot in
97 okay Knight b5 not yet you have ideas
of bringing the knight to h5 harass a
queen and put pressure on that for a
little far also e4 is hanging right yeah
now e4 sneaking you can take with
knights and then you'll have f5 if he
ends very good okay this is good this is
great um Queen b6 yeah I want to get out
of the 4 maybe double okay that's fine
too this is great
rookie for or Queenie sick rookie four
looks good Queen e6 could maybe trade
winds though yeah you can go for that
nice okay now it's just some
game technique you might want to play a
5 at some point to prevent white from
playing 85 I know it weakens b6 but you
put your look back on e6 okay and then
bring the king yeah okay this is very
positional you have like unlimited time
promise it's not easy to break through
okay oh that's okay um I think you I
mean taking the bishop because you'll
have rook b6 and end okay he takes a
five rupee seven king c6 rook takes g7
d3 honestly I think you should you
should take the bishop and put the King
on eh and then go after the b2 pawn okay
Rippey six and now take and then now
you're gonna win c4 so you take on b2
with check and then you want to win yes
that's why your king is back to help
defend that's true actually but he's
also threatening rook c7 so you have to
go and win the C pawn that's very good
sign and now you can you can work your
way up
rook c3 very good I could play rook f3
you know you wanna lose a c5 pawn
what about c4 c4 is a fine move to start
with yeah he's preparing h5 though let's
find your king is what they raise King
f7 king of seven looks good yeah he's
gonna check so disrespectful the engines
nowadays no manners oh you have to play
rook t3 check yeah and then probably
king f7 again and then you might have to
go for Qing Yi seven it's risky but
you'll get into ArcheAge three row gauge
- what about going for the a pawn that's
also true
rook a3 also an idea oh right here
you can have two pawns yeah your rook is
stuck though so he's gonna win one of
the pawns back okay three rook takes
rook a4 with the idea of rook before
yeah the problem is he's gonna start
checking you on like the seventh and
eighth okay I was thinking the best
tries to play King nice King f7 King g7
is still or and now now I'm rook h3 rook
h3 to H 2 and now yeah that's a very
tricky though it's hard to make progress
and then see 3 mm and then King rookie -
should I try that rooks you - yeah
Trixie - ok now actually if you can
maybe play King e7 Keeney 7 to d6 kick
away the rook and then you want to get
c3 to create mating ideas now it's a
question what move order or King D 6
yeah so before I can't chase honestly
even even king g6 immediately because
now the rook can't move to eat c5 or d5
and now no c3 yes III should be good
yeah no King D 5044 there's no more
checks
now move your rook like each - yeah he's
gonna sec right probably King III and
now King f3 yeah oh so you okay this is
completely winning I mean you can play
rook h1 you can play rook rook e8 - even
okay - yeah okay - looks great yeah just
watch out for your time okay this is
great
okay next I think using an engine he is
engine player report
so we're on level 14 rights yes oh okay
okay okay so we have another one of
these lines let me check on the
competition Dennis on 13 as black so we
just wear half or one point ahead okay
and planet chess club is on thirteen
with black so there's still still
grinding some those are you ready oh
yeah you started I started to see the
game no problem yeah we have a blue bot
and if you guys want more information
about it here is the link to the
overview please check it up oh my gosh
what's what is it doing
I can take a pawn I think yeah okay oh
there's might be three ideas okay so I
have to move to Bishop
so a Bishop d2 oh wait a minute be very
careful here let's play Bishop there now
I can take the pawn take on d4 words yes
oh no it's still night b3 okay I'm gonna
try some endgame okay well we're down
I'm down the piece I know I was going to
try to like I mean I have some puns and
that's true you do have some puns you
could give it a go I guess why do we
call community because in English
grammar it's usually male is the go to
standards okay that did not work I'm
gonna try it again so it's playing this
like feeding kettle line let's play f3
Wow f5 novelty maybe just gonna be solid
yeah okay good
Bishop e2 g4 okay like a G maybe I'm
very nice f4 looks good it's solid
where's the night go only have b3 okay
now night be to fee encounter the
Knights mm-hmm
safety first we care about the bishop no
it's gonna waste time bring the rook in
yeah I like it
okay now the dark squared Bishop is kind
of scary so let's play e5 shut the
bishop down okay do you want to take
back on d4 Queen h2 probably Queen takes
d4 want to control a five mm-hmm okay
this is very annoying threats Knight c3
coming yeah we have 94 but then you'll
attack the knight maybe for Bishop d7
yeah exactly
there's like c4 Knight c4 is actually
kind of interesting return there chief
oh okay yeah it worked nice line maybe
move the rook to h1 so that you don't
get you know just a low Knight c3 and
yeah King bee - I guess so called a few
kiddo when it's night yeah I guess so if
you kiddo night
we're on Twitter I will are they oh hey
guys good to see you two jokers I hope
you're having fun we're on level 14 by
the way we're leading our division the
rest of the division is scared but we
gotta focus
okay the Knights pinned to the rook on
h1 and it's actually not easy to like
fix I could play rook I'll play rook f1
let's move the Queen back now let's take
Bishop g2 fee encountering in our
territory after looks Oh recap - I like
very good double off the rooks like this
Wow okay so there are we setting on g6
not yet if you played so quickly wait a
minute can we take we can't take on 87
or can we takes bishop takes e5 takes
takes
mmm it's so close to work you may have
Queen h5 in the end but yeah I like that
as well and now we can take yeah I guess
makes me 500 takes e5 we can oh it's
still tricky
and it's so close it is very close maybe
he missed it we shouldn't think he found
it just because it's I mean I'm gonna
play g4 probably no I still want to take
there and complete Queen h3 to build up
dannion has love that I'm glad to hear
it okay rook takes h7 Bishop takes e5
Queen takes h5 rook takes 87 work 687
take everything Queen h5 King g7 Queen
66 King is running though it's a problem
you also have Queen h3 yeah it might I
don't but I mean Bishop takes e4 is
coming I might play g5 Knight g4 and
Knight f6 okay seems more solid okay
that's a good sign or is it
if takes are we worried about him taking
on a 2 we can't really defend it I guess
yes I mean it's annoying I think I'm
gonna go for Knight g4 to f6 the play
Queen h3 here I'm taking a gamble but no
taking work this works so the challenge
ends in three hours and a half and in
your division whatever level you got to
whoever got to the highest level and if
two people got to the same level then
who got there in the fastest time that's
how you win okay I think I'd blender
everything like it's it's defending or
how it's defending that it's defending
everything take on g6 and hope for the
best
okay let's go for it again 114 he is
he's a trickster again we have plenty of
time we're doing better than the
competition so yeah I'm gonna hope it
falls into some trap like okay here we
have the line again okay you're a London
expert you are the real Como
here Komodo learns the London by looking
at Eric Rosen gates
that's that might be true actually yeah
g4 okay this is what I like to see cuz
now queen h3 or Queen f3 to h3 that
looks very nice now we want to somehow
break down the H file so queen h3 start
with okay he's fighting some counterplay
maybe before between h5 okay now this is
actually a very critical moment because
f4 and g5 and I think it's crashing
through like take some G photos there's
93 yeah I think taking on e4 and g5 and
it looks so good I don't think there's
any any like immediate counterplay yeah
I like it okay yeah no checks he's
preparing Queen b5
maybe but each is defended so I think we
might end up winning a piece at least
okay oh he's gonna play g6 but wouldn't
g6 might takes g6 okay that should be
good too yep so we could take on g6 and
play some end game and then if you
thinks the Queen I'm guessing you play
97 check right many seven rook takes the
Knights kind of awkward but looking for
something better at age 7 are we
smothered mating somehow each 17 eh-eh
Queen takes you six doesn't quite work I
don't think wait a minute h7 King h8
here cage what do you plan for KJ Queen
g5 is he can't play off 6 will play
Queen D eights I think that's a safer
line then we can if the very least trade
Queens okay good yeah take your time
Ben on 14 now thanks guys we're gonna
we're gonna get it so close to mate need
some help here I am looking for ideas
and I was trying to see if there's any
way we could bring the other rook in
it's too slow
[Music]
well maybe Brooke h6 and then we're are
we threatening anything okay 6:30 okay
so six were threatening h8 Queen
actually so yeah now H a queen rook
takes from tix hero he is King f8 yeah
so close
Oh what about rook takes pawn takes
Queen e7 King h8 that's gotta be working
right
wait wait wait what's the line again
rook takes no no he gets on h6
rook takes pawn takes if you place King
h8 it's made I don't know what happens
if he plays after Queen e7 if he plays
King h6 mm-hmm so I'm looking at H a
queen takes takes King f8 and then rook
g7 all the probably's work h1 in the end
and we get made it it's so close I'm
thinking about castling queenside and
then well the Queen can't get too far
away
wait do we have rook takes c6 and Queen
e7 ideas that's what I was looking at
before if you placed King h8 its mate
but what happens after King h6 King age
694 King h5 and then we win the Queen
with Knight f6 ok
pretty slow okay yeah oh no we the rook
can take wait but maybe we're still
winning Knight of 6 take sticks and then
we're promoting or can we block what
about h8 Queen yes it take and then we
have rickets Knight of 6 oh that's
actually might be might be genius takes
takes because we might get made it on h1
yeah let's play h8 Queen first okay okay
now we take now we take yeah this tricky
but okay I mean it should be which looks
kind of anointing or castling castling
might be just meeting yeah let's castle
never too late to castle before
it's Chuck
okay so it's some work we did it your
turn okay all right let's get in some
French let's go back into what we've
been doing I play very similar lines
here I'm gonna let you do your thing I'm
gonna grab some cranberry juice real
quick yeah I like what I see
I like wants to be poor but I think 94
is dangerous cuz he can't actually stop
okay
d4 does it do anything maybe rook c8
first no you can block I don't want him
to be able to block the diagonal with
his knife
I think deep or might actually be good
here
d4 you can take with night if he takes
with pawn yeah that's what I'm trying to
find out if I have any compensation with
rook e8 I mean you might want to throw
in f6 first like try and break down
because this night it's still kind of
stuck on f3 well he can he can play 94
next move if I play f6 and then king f7
I mean yeah the game keeps going I mean
it's interesting it's definitely an
option I was thinking like f6 and then
just bring the king to e7 and keep all
the tension okay okay yeah king f7 yeah
very good we agree on this okay and now
can you say yeah okay
'if I've not yet cuz yes checks 92 I
like 92 looks nice yeah kick the bishop
oh we have to watch out for the point
maybe you can take on f3 and if King
takes
oh nevermind sorry I
can play Bishop c8 but then I lose on b5
I could push you 5 if I could actually
be interesting and then you take on na u
5 in an F sighs you know you should do
probably just 94 back just block the
file
what about yeah but that's a move you
can prepare so I mean maybe put the
bishop c8 and then B seven no because it
gives checks yeah you lose support of
the the four night to you guys might
think the French is boring but I mean
you might want to play six and then
Bishop c8 yeah actually King no King d6
he's gonna take ooh
he didn't take he could have taken on e4
and then give discoveries you don't want
your King on the same files of rook
you're right I think I should push f5 go
for that yeah yeah you close things down
and now you you can start preparing on
day five yeah very good and now a very
good I like it
in our case taking the rook F a8 rook a
to and just start penetrating maybe take
on C through maybe Bishop d7 first so we
want to keep the bishop we want to
because we don't want to take on c3
right away yeah we wanted to fend e6
yeah yeah I got it before at some point
is interesting yeah like rook maybe rook
b8 just to prepare before Oh
apparently not cus mother made it that's
pretty well okay before we have to watch
out for c4 though I mean this is where
we just want to play controlled chess I
mean you have two minutes left
yeah just some time yeah honestly that's
not a bad option like everything's
covered and now and now before very good
now I can take
take back because oh I thought ahead
that's okay that's it's so efficient
just take back yeah and you have pawns
I do have funds yes question is how to
make progress you want to break through
at some points well see Maria's gonna
come if he takes on e4 right yeah before
as good as a goner anyway yeah I know I
maybe maybe King do six like activate
the King get the key Muffy file and
prepare Bishop c6 to d5 your bishop
wants to be on d5 I'm happy right I
believe more powerful d5 yeah probably
rook I mean maybe rook c8 that's okay
King c5 yeah rook c8 okay and no I mean
after is actually annoying I can also
play rook g8 provoke him a little see
what he does cuz if you moves the rook
and we push if he moves a3 that we have
h5 okay go for it yeah just now no cuz
I'm g5 so move back to see it that's a
good move or I think kini 5 is also
playable no checkmates no mates take
with Bishop now I think c3 c3 might lead
to a winning like King pawn ending okay
that's right c3 take on D - yeah and now
take on c3 with the rook I believe I
think with rook okay
and now take and now be very very
careful King f5 yes King f5 and now King
F for annual you'll promote the pawn
before he he promotes no no
okay that's that's also fine now okay
very very important
kingi three I believe team XIII you're
sure Oh actually play h5 first and now
take the oh my gosh I'm so sorry okay
it's for ya yeah there is time trouble
there as each pawn is tricky
we were very close oh my god okay
alright so Komodo 14 again yeah okay
yeah I just have to take a little bit of
care to attend you came
telling me how the other teams are doing
just for my yeah if someone can share a
standings link in the chat I know
they're standing somewhere on smash GG I
didn't play this French line as well as
I usually do what kind of move is that
it's actually okay like maybe you got
your your attack again like a 5 before
Roxy it's a 5 e for thank you scale as
for the two months okay casts a little
Queen side and bring the rooks over or
is that too risky King e7 also an option
94 could also just confuse him a little
or Queen b6 and then push a 4 I think
you won't you want to play kind of
slowly c4 is very OC before you can on
passant though yeah and now now you
probably want the castle I don't think
it longer stands it wants to attack you
on the Kings side and your king safe too
okay which probably the a rook
yeah I like it oh that's not me oh it's
so close so you have Bishop f5 oh so
close
it is it was very close rook c8 yeah
there's gonna be Trixie one takes takes
rook Estill pins you know you know what
I would probably try rook rook F c8
takes takes and then King h7 threatening
rook c8 oh my bad
that was bad we're trading Queens resign
the new game okay alright let's ease
tactics
it's not easy that's why I like trading
okay so it looks like everyone's on 14
14 black or white I'm not sure we were
so close that other game but it doesn't
matter cuz we will get it this time I
think chess is in the chats can
hopefully share the link okay slow and
steady do your thing
yeah I mean you might just want to
castle sooner here and then go fraid
like put the rook on African b8 okay
that's a really weird move yeah I'm just
a 5 and hopefully before that's okay
actually you're opening files this is
good just take take with a pawn okay
okay this is very very good sign no no
we're gonna do the same thing as last
time no you want to be careful about
before queen
what about Queen a5 a5 there's my kicks
before I mean that should be good for
you I I would say go for Queen a5 and
now 84 no this is critical moments yeah
I mean 94 I like the idea Knight c3 stop
it with the rook right away I guess
the thing is the queen is tied down too
the fending like if Knights 94 rook to
e3 Knight c3 still you have Queen a1 in
the end and as Queens also defending the
Knights so I believe this is just
crushing I mean if you want to you can
you have Queen takes before night a 2
and you'll be up a piece but there might
be something quicker okay just take take
before yeah I mean you still play it
safe like okay very good work I like I
like Bishop c6 defend solid you have to
defend your Knights I mean you everybody
I say play 92 and repeats maybe if he
goes back okay - yeah I'll take yeah
very good okay now now it's just simple
like stay calm or state control I like
it
yeah win the pot make lifts for the King
good yeah bring the knight back to d5
and then try and just trade rooks and
winning any game yep I'll get set up
okay maybe Kings d6 yeah oh nice okay
very good
now just hopefully winning King pawn in
d h5 yeah thank you so much just be
careful like five King g5 fine okay
thank you so much Donovan I will read it
once Eric starts doing his thing and
we've beaten this okay yeah just watch
out don't still me with your Knights you
are very right just Queen c2 or that
okay and queen bee
yeah and one more queen bee five
oh no this works
I really appreciate it thank you so much
Fergus drunken munkey Janek Sharik
laughing T jibber judo fat extender once
you force the cardi and devote a Porsche
welcome to the sub club well make sure
to thank the awesome son of n welcome to
the family guys oh I don't see your game
I already started it's falling into the
Sun it's tricky this time wow that's
being very tricky it's getting stronger
coach chess is also on the 15 but we
just need to take our time okay I mean
I'm my position might be falling apart
but it might be also winning no don't
worry about it we still got that w okay
I'm paying attention now okay I mean I'm
going for the kill like immediately or
at least trying to play rook F c1 and
then probably take with the rock and lux
just disobeying like principles yes King
okay this is a good sign it's not really
consolidating I've maybe Knight bd4
right maybe t4 looks Pleasant I don't
see it better okay okay now it does rook
takes d7 work rotation saab you can't 67
a queen chuck and then 95 in the end and
there's no way to defend mate right I
mean this has got this we already here
this has to work yes tricked yes yes a
London opening preparation I like so
much respect so much respect okay okay
shooter is really annoying against Kings
Indians but here we go okay just get in
I mean this is still level you can be
solid and it should give you something
at some points unless you give it
something first
okay I think we have better shot in
these French lines we have way a better
shot in the French lines like maybe play
e6 see what happens you're welcome I
really like it we're just getting
experience in this line you might start
playing this yourself at some point like
castling a5 b 4 rook b8 or take
oh maybe rook b8 i like then you Bishop
takes e7 you have to take it back back
with the night that's fine yeah it's
like it can I take on 8th floor with the
night
yeah I'm calculating Knight takes a
floor bishop takes takes I'll Ike it
yeah go for it go for it and Queen takes
c3 here this is crushing no you might
just have to retreat and then you'll
have a four ideas
question is where does your Queen move
Queen before Queen before there's going
to be Queen d4 rook t4 Queen c6 I was
thinking Queen c7 just to give your
bishop some happiness I like it and now
Queen b7 how's he gonna put oh yes Queen
d4 to protect me I'm wondering if you
can't just like triple up on the V file
like maybe start with rook b4 and then
rook a b8 slow
play okay c3 is some concession
I mean maybe Brooke b7 yeah be sudden
sure okay double the rooks or Bishop b5
and Bishop c5 or a3 there's a ton of
options here I like Bishop b5 if there
should be five to see for a three okay
this is where we want to slow down I
think what we want to do is prevent pawn
b3 like rook b3 followed by a three
three looks really annoying but he
pushes c4 yeah I really like rook b3
very controlled but then use it up like
Queen D for Queen g4 than just simple
Queen B 5 yeah hold him down a3 looks
good looks like just about meaning just
take okay now stay calm and converts and
I'll get ready for next game rook e8
take the rook and from Magic Remote very
good I'll be on level 16 nice Queen
ephors mates yeah your turn I'm just
playing some new line it's playing very
strangely this is like level one but
it's level 16 at some point it's gonna
figure out the French oh my gosh it did
it just trap my bishop I hope there
should be five maybe though oh my gosh
what is this queen g4 maybe being ultra
aggressive here queenside castling 95
Wow noise are we doing well I like to
hear
I might resign this game if I'm not
getting enough compensation that's okay
I'm still gonna try and get some attack
though I'm just looking like where's my
comp can play queen
Kings running to g8 I'm gonna go for a
g3 and then Queen here and takes maybe
I'll get overexcited over tea 395 Bishop
g2 looked good yeah I'm actually
beginning to like the position again
yeah maybe Queenie four okay five is
annoying do we have to play Queen d5 I
think so 907 at some point we oh we
don't have Queen h4 in Queens so close
okay you have to play rook g2 and
prevent insult me
I see what you mean maybe rook does this
work
Bishop e2 the other there should be 2
Queen take C to work h1 or gauge 6 take
sticks check I'm gonna go for that okay
I respect it mm-hmm it's disrespecting
it I know okay okay okay
solid come over 16 you said good game
he's so polite big profit yeah I wonder
that's happening chat thanks for being
so supportive I know I've been
responding to comments a little less
today since we are in a competition we
have to have slow focus but I really
appreciate you guys being here you're
watching supporting Magnus lair aka Eric
Rosen also also ditto that to all my
viewers - yes I wish I could speak as
well as you Alexandra no okay everybody
knows oh okay I'm pinned I can't move
let's move there oh my gosh okay that
was bad I liked my position and so I
look away for a second yeah it's okay a
new challenge I'm gonna try and slow
down fifteen weekend we're favored level
increase in strength only go to 200
points
oh yeah you read we want to play black
well it keeps putting his back
appreciate ya kimono 16 with white I'm
getting faster at challenging it kind of
good the game's not starting though you
aborted there okay
it's so many people trying to play with
the friendly Komodo yeah okay so we have
a similar line let's defend the b-pawn
do this move takes okay I like the
structure I want to play Bishop c4 in
blunder queen bee for Moto 21 would be
like 2700 probably higher 28 b3 defend
everything and let's bring the knight to
g3 how much all that's that later chat
if anybody knows I'm gonna go into a nun
game ooh I do i plunger actually this is
really interesting now before ideas
Queen c7 Bishop c7 ideas well before it
takes some Queen b3
oh there's work f7 in the end let's try
that and then take here take another net
continue yeah oh this isn't working
though okay it's getting tougher of
course
okay all done
but last or the the first games are just
too quick yeah I think we need to slow
down a little bit to make sure that it's
something a little confusing with
opening so again it's taking a few
seconds to starts it's just City that's
okay note to self study Eric Rosen games
for the London I'm not kidding I'm gonna
do that alright mmm sudden oh I've G for
here G for yeah it's complicated though
it is you could just take the night
first and then play G for oh that might
be agree right but then you'll take on
five that's the problem so it takes only
five you take on f5 you run his pawn
structure let's do that and I'll take Oh
or maybe this is even better it's
similar yeah yeah so it's a very strange
structure I think I'll leave the tension
between a shipping neither for is coming
but I want h5 at some points they maybe
take some than h5 and I might even sack
the exchange I don't think it'll take it
though so tak looks way too strong
okay so it doesn't take now it's
threatening taking on here and III I'm
playing Bishop g3 queen g4 idea maybe
just takes it fun g6 and then take with
check yeah the thing is takes on g6
takes on e3 but you take H seven let's
check if he takes on e3 yeah actually
that looks okay the problem looks like
there's there's Bishop g3 in the end I
don't know if it does anything though I
also have also have queen h5 here which
could just be winning okay we have to
calculate Queen h5 threatening me than
one there's it's not too many moves
there's no G - thank you - but there's
not too many annoying tracks as Knight G
- and then King D or King d1 King do you
want allows Queen g4 that's true and we
can't play king d2 cuz
okay so let's calculate Queen 8h 592
king good play king d drinking's you
want oh wait wait wait wait what's wrong
with Queen h5 92 King d1 ah good point
okay so h6 good now the thing is if we
take there's no G - King d1 Queen g4
butter King King run and rook takes off
- King b3 I think this is winning
we can also just take the night but I've
I don't see anything wrong with this
night I feel like you'll be able to get
out of this okay that's a good sign now
you have king c1 and there's normal
checks you can see one good points okay
does Mac have any way to stop meat after
King c1 yes rook f1 no that allows on h8
I think this is winning I don't think
I'm just making sure yeah that's a great
sign good sign that means regardless
it's a very good sign okay okay
highest you team beat seventeen for some
French it's almost amusing it's fine no
you're getting your amazing position
every single time for novelty 94-94 is
an idea I mean you might want to keep
your noise might be too is also
interesting might be seven you mean yes
I was thinking like D seven and then
maneuver your knight to be six
eventually okay I don't know if it's too
slow but we'll find out but the computer
is also playing kind of slowly so now
bishop be sad anymore
watch your pond yeah I really like the
position just have to take it slowly
wait wait wait wait do you have d4 here
just winning material like d4 unleash
the bishop or sorry sorry cuz the the D
pawn is pinned
so he's ripped team one sorry what Oh
cuz I can't yeah you know good point I
mean it's still a great position at some
point you want to castle yeah castling
run away might make a lot of sense
moving the Queen somewhere like c7 is
threatening d4 cuz the knights protected
that's an idea to say I like castling
because
you you get your King safe and you
prepare the rook take with the pawn
I mean you can still consider d4 but
probably take with a pawn first because
a file is now open
yeah and now now there's some meaning
but you can't take it because be pawn is
still pinned or the be pawns vulnerable
right so you might have like Bishop c6
here like Bishop c6 Queen g3 you have to
play Queen b7 it's still a great
position and take on c6 yep and they'll
probably rook fb8 yep okay hmm maybe
Queen c7 I mean your Queens attacked so
yeah I have to do that there's also
roque three ideas like rook a3 where it
doesn't like go well it's not under
attack yet oh that's true
so maybe yeah so maybe 96 yeah 96 to c4
right away I think so okay
Tamas White's now kind of safe with the
king we still want to break down the
position somehow yeah I mean I could
also play something like 90 you know
what move I like is queenie sudden ideas
of Queen h4 also ideas of rook a3 you
want to work both sides of the board
okay if it's winning pawn or anything
I'm 93 yeah music sigh guess Queenie
sevens are more practical like more
positional okay I'm done because now you
can sneak in doesn't that attack as much
I have no work a two doesn't work I'm
like in Queen h4 here just simple ideas
like okay take back on me six Wow
I mean the Kings still very unsafe on he
too
I have rook da ya then Queen takes c4
unfortunately I mean that's still
playable it's still playable
there's also Knight takes e5 is
interesting just well the whole Center
opens up the Kings kind of naked yeah so
we need to decide what to try here
honestly I kind of like Knight takes e5
because go win g4 in a lot of lines Wow
that's playing like a computer you don't
say but I mean this has to be good for
you with this King it's just a matter of
like concrete calculation I mean rook
rook a fake Queen jz5 should be winning
for you because you you check and win
the rook with Queen f2 okay Knight f3 is
it makes things crazy but there might be
an option in case we don't have choice
because we're also getting a little yeah
Queen e7 no he just takes the knight and
I have no more attack he also starting
Queen d8 to trade if I do anything
that's the point
maybe rook see Roxy aids probably
doesn't work I'm determined to go for
Knight f3 3 alpha middle of rook c8
Queen takes e5 rook takes you to or
Queen takes or no each egg is my queen
ok I'm kind of liking rook c8 here you
go after the C to pawn g4 still tender I
think it's the best chance Queen takes G
for now okay now you want to just win
the rook so Queen f3 you'll win the rook
yeah he's threatening mate though on g7
but you you have Queen c3 and rook c4
maybe this is the time you have to play
quick - yeah rook c5 doesn't work maybe
Queen c4 check no this is bad
you have no checks Oh Queen before check
maybe
ya think this is over that's okay
we were very close so it was good attack
tough level just new game move on okay
sixteen thanks chess calm okay let's go
again back from class hey no let's try
this okay oh okay still do your friend
stuff yeah okay he's canceling the other
way I don't think that's too much of an
issue
mm-hmm so tie trade off and then night
in the center for now okay he just
closes that's fine yeah this is more
positional than the ops it's like
castling you want to probably play g6
and it is I think when you six it looks
reasonable then he gets 95 ideas - I can
also wait and play h6 yeah I mean it's a
difficult position already but there's
also like g6 ideas I close things down
yeah yeah h6 is a good option yeah
because now I can at least Castle and
maybe get out of this it's actually
playing pretty well like positionally
maybe rook f d8
over defend the night so your has more
mobility now queen g4 only move okay you
would like to bring the night like ISA
you see you have to watch out for f7 but
I think it's okay like 9 f8 c e6 should
be okay take on D 4th Chuck yes so no I
get it
good still need to make sure yeah
because it's blocking the night maybe
rook f8 just to be safe yeah
um I heard something okay I don't know
what I heard
okay sorry what did you say rook f8 just
to be safe okay oh that's okay that's on
your string good I was getting confused
oh yeah okay rook c8 maybe ACH yeah yeah
now you actually are playing it yeah
good now we want to play rook c1 so
maybe queen of four house it's awkward
c1
yeah and there's no counter player just
rook c1 just stay calm okay win and then
take on d4 okay it actually played
really well like earlier but just
collapsed okay get ready for seventeen
maybe make another Queen take the knight
very good weird I'm telling you the
French defense is really intimidating
mm-hmm III I'm not a French player but
I'm really admiring like these wow it's
playing like a Justine ID tag Justine in
like 20 moves but I think we take
speeches a mistake okay I showed this
line in my London course I have to
remember preparation there's like Bishop
d2 I believe does not agree I know
there's some weird lines here on Bishop
c4 like somehow the Queen gets trapped
but it's confusing yeah and honestly
it's based on computer preparation which
is kind of unsettling like I could take
a draw but like oh yeah so okay okay I
think I got it so rook b1 I sucked the a
pawn now the pawns
Penda now I play Bishop c4 like Bishop
c4 takes takes takes takes it just works
okay this is a good sign I have to take
here we're still doing well on the
pairings chat this is winning
oh this it's chaotic position but I like
my chances
yeah I agree I'm up to exchange for pawn
or two pawns but the Kings on g8 so when
do you play Bishop not yet 92 normally
92 safety first
your rook rook might be getting trapped
while Queenie sevens a threat my stock
with a 7 well that might have to sack
back and see it which is still
interesting oh there's nine of four
ideas not a floor might be playable
actually I'm gonna try this what does
this move
c3 what okay maybe it's just like
stalling play Bishop c1 you can also
cancel or remove your bishop yeah
promise queen a7 will come like a castle
actually castling is not a bad idea
castling takes takes Queen a7 takes
takes six Oh Cal Castle thanks for the
recommendation
oh but I lose a knight I'm so sorry
but maybe it's still not bad because see
it's very loose right physics and now I
have Queen a1 Robin he has Queen c6
defending Queen c6 and then I think I
have to just take the pawn and then you
have d5 that's kind of a battle for time
yeah now the Queen comes to eight now I
have to like attack the bishop with my
f1 rook right so you can also have rugby
one and rook takes b7 yeah that's why
I'm looking at there's Queen taxi - when
there's Queen takes b7 you know for this
oh I missed that idea but I can take on
be siding with this rook mm-hmm-hmm
still not easy cuz kinis
Evans coming he is getting out of this
in a very annoying fashion you know III
bikini seven will come looking for last
tricks I'll play Rick okay yeah I'm
probably gonna resign soon but I'm still
fighting yeah guys try not to post moves
I mean I haven't looked at the chat
enough to see anything but just in case
so we don't get it yeah honestly I have
not been looking the chat like yeah
almost at all very thin thanks for being
here you and me okay um yeah we can look
for less tricks and then it's still
giving me like weird chances like it
gets a winning position then it starts
blundering you if you plate quickly it
has less time to calculate that's
another idea but then I have more
options than you also you also do yeah I
know man versus machine let's play a bad
move it doesn't take my rook now maybe I
could move this way oh but now I blunder
but maybe not this move in this move and
I still want to like go for mates okay
never mind
okay all right
another London will play this Lane
yeah the sign is playing c5 which is a
kind of a dubious attack
welcome back play c3 yeah I'm very
comfortable in these sort of positions
play 95 now guys that 20 nice who would
have guessed
93 there's also no I 14 there's my g3 so
let's play let's play tonight a six is
coming unfortunately
hmm maybe g4g for make things spicy
now th5 i'm playing very aggressively
I've noticed but it's worked most of the
time yeah it's just kind of out of my
style but it's fun I want to play like
so many things I want to do in this
position f3 but I can't I have to defend
the pawn maybe I take very good
maybe Bishop f4 Bishop f4 defending the
pawn in defending g3 and now maybe h6
starts okay very good sign yeah cuz
h-file is like very dangerous now yep
even know if I'm not winning immediately
or f1 Queen h2 yeah I like that idea
there's my chief 595 work h5 that's why
f3 then he has 696 queen h2 is still
coming right right okay I mean it might
play f6
but then me we can keep the tension play
Knight g4 let's try this now Knight d4
decentralizing Knights
I'd like to keep initiative Hey but 94
looks nice 54 looks good you can't take
on e5 I mean I could take on g5 take on
e6 but I don't wanna separate right I
think I'll castle castle and all the
pressure I like the castling mm maybe
just rook h1 and build up more pressure
or yeah I think we just gotta keep
putting the pressure here now there's
ideas of taking enough 6 work h6 and
mini six
[Music]
trying to calculate rook takes g5 to
because it's also like forcing take
sticks it's a difficult situation
techsan g5 rook takes d5 Knight takes c6
this also takes and then rook I take c6
first also interesting the problem is
like actually g6 in the very end
maybe it's playable I'm thinking about
rotates g5 first and try and get some
ending where I can takes with pawn
Knight takes c6 it'll be good structure
in there wow it's going for this line Oh
is there mate on age 7 yeah I probably
have to try to take the rope there is it
there is Queen d3 within Queen e7 let's
try this I'm okay probably end up
resigning well shot too strong yeah how
much time do we have left
oh we started at 2:15 okay um so it's
been about two hours and a half so yeah
a little over an hour okay I'm trying to
send the challenge again your whites and
Feingold still on 16 Conte on 14 planet
chess club on 15 okay okay it's playing
the line I like again at least one of
the lines okay great I guess maybe last
time we could have taken any slight edge
and just try to convert us soon as we
get that yeah I mean again okay I love
the position it really underestimates
the power of the open file like I might
already be winning here with vertex h5
like rook takes h5 g takes h5 queen h6
yes so maybe queen h6 immediately but
there's Queen takes b2 but that these
lines are fascinating to calculate takes
age five we sack of rook we sack both
rooks for amazed and the ends Kimmy -
Queen B - 90 - it might be working he
also has Queen takes c3 check and
threatening the bishop oh that's a good
point
wait but no we're already threatening
made on h8 when we take on each five oh
but then humans a 5 mm it's so close to
working between age 6 Queen takes b2
rook takes age 5 Queen takes c3 me - can
you eat - Queen B - check and then Queen
takes e5 chip with check oh then after
Queen B - I mean Queen h6 Queen takes B
to maybe just rook c1 I mean it looks
kind of risky but I mean I mean let
start with Queen h6 because I don't know
if it's going to take on b2 okay it
takes one B - okay
now rook c1 others Bishop a3 wait a
minute we work I mean I feel like he's
good at calculating the problem with
rook see one there's Bishop e3 and it
looks very strange counterplay but then
maybe Knight g5 you're up do you one and
king f1 no it's too slow it's also
Bishop I'm gonna try rook seen one okay
that's this is a very good sign because
now I think Bishop takes g6 might just
be winning back on h4
oh you mean take on a chore immediately
or why is Bishop d6 winning because
we're threatening made in one it takes
ticks King h8 as promised I reckon c1
still hanging right but we also can't
take back on h4 with the rook is what
I'm sure is oh oh yeah I mean Knight
takes h4
I mean we're so close to winning this
okay just trying to calculate concretely
vishal takes you six ticks ticks Kimia
chips queen h6 defending the rocking g8
mm-hmm
still very difficult I can take with
pawn maybe and then ideas of Knight g5
onaji find the star right now I was
thinking also take with Knights like
nineteen states for what's this back to
you yeah I'm just gonna take with the
Knights cuz I don't see what's coming I
like it thank you so much for the tiny
gift subs and on you're the best
I appreciate it now I think I can just
castle thank you so much
other special takes f2o but that doesn't
do anything
and castling seems so wrong but also so
right there's also Bishop Bishop c2
doesn't work I'm gonna try is yes I
don't want to leave my rook or pull my
work on that fine Roxy it to you o UT
okay
it's so close to winning it is but not
how to defend Bishop Bishop e2 queen of
four doesn't work I'm in the castle okay
not what I wanted to do but now I have
95 ideas and now G 4G fork g3 and King G
to bringing the rook over yeah I like it
maybe g5 even I'm a chief I know g5 he
just takes the bishop yeah
mmm-maybe 94 here d4 looks nice okay no
kingi - okay this is a very good sign
now takes mean that's almost meeting
very good I think I'll just play rook
each one first and now where's the mate
it's made than three right Queenie
southern King f8 Queen a chick King f7
didn't rotate seven his mates you said
that so fast
all right next game okay took some
efforts amazing that was crying
it's tough mate it's okay focus we have
time there's hour and five minutes left
I believe do you Matt this is I mean
I've checked all of this computer so
many times it's okay no I like this line
if I mean if white castle's Queen side
we're in very good shape can you do your
thing okay he's gonna Castle kingside
yep probably you could Castle kingside
first it's flexible okay so we're gonna
have a positional game we might want to
play g6 like sooner rather than later
I could also try f6 here actually cause
if he castles it's fine for me and if
you play yeah actually yeah go for it
interest okay so he I can just take
resigned new game okay I'll slow it down
oh sorry I'll fix the board I'll fix the
board we're back we're back we're back
sorry guys the board is fixed all as
well okay
I'm different line maybe try and get
your structure like yeah c5 good you
know more than this and me I assume you
play off six at some points yeah maybe
Queen b6 first these lines are
definitely trickier yeah Queen b6 might
be three maybe oh and then
f 6 right I could take on d4 and play
that but it's much more text o as Assam
Milner berry yeah okay so what you're
supposed to do is move the Queen oh wait
this is different though I just thought
Queen b6 the Queen b6 looks fine you're
up upon he likes the development and now
I play h6 okay Bishop c5 oh good point
and then trade trade Queens trying you
can probably I mean I don't know if you
want the castle you can probably get
away with castling that's true so like I
mean like be secretary yeah Knight b6 I
mean like b6 looks solid
Bishop goes to c6 eventually now Queen
e7 when you say it I like it
we should play this right yeah I mean
Bishop d7 I think the next few moves are
pretty natural okay
and then rook c8 be careful of rook c7
it's still okay like you have rook b8
here alright okay no I think you want to
play like you want to trade rooks
obviously yeah FC 8 right away is there
anything he has any tricks I don't think
so
he just has to double right yeah I think
you're happy to trade rooks and then I
could play Queen d8 here uh yeah Queen D
it's I like it hey I mean maybe even
like rook c6 and then prepare your own
double up Brooke c6 if he pushes b5 then
retail can you take yeah and then we see
it to follow
rook c8 right away super protected
there's no worries here yeah you just
want to trade like simplify control off
everything you're great okay so Bishop
d7 Bishop before what do we like Bishop
d7 you should be 7c eggs you know I need
to try to get the Queen and then convert
this watch out for your a7 pony oh and I
can't move right away yes good point I
mean you could play Queen c1 here a3 is
tender
hinder I like that word okay now watch
out for Queen d8 I don't know if it's
actually oh it is a made into threat
so maybe Queen Queen c7 maybe you can go
after E 5 like Queen c7 Bishop c6 and
then Knight d7 play Queen e8 Queen e7
sorry yeah which is annoying I mean I
could just play my Queen back to c8 you
also have night c8 there and just kick
the Queen away true okay so let's try
Queen c7 and kick it out if it gets to
yes Oh does he have anything like Knight
g5 there's no threats I just leave it I
just leave okay
thanks for the bits gay koala please
stop stop posting too much you gotta
slow it down a little it was a two
second timeout so you're not in trouble
okay I think your your Knights should
maneuver to c87 yeah and maybe start
with e six yeah fix upon and now your
queen I mean everything is protected
from now
I mean Bishop ei and Queenie seven maybe
and then put your queen on c5 Queen C
597 great and now bring your Bishop back
to b7 e7 okay let's do some rerouting
here okay okay now your knight needs to
find a good square if I could get it to
do my night is really
but the e5 pawn is also under attack so
maybe I could play Queens
I mean Queen c7 see if it's going to
play out for do we like that I mean it's
gonna come regardless I'm just curious
if yeah okay you probably have to break
at some points with like got six so
maybe you put the bishop back on d7 and
try and organize an f6 break there's a
d7 and now maybe King maybe King h8
night she ate an f6 and open up the long
diagonal for the Queen yeah we wanna
because White's just waiting so
now f6 take on Tate I don't mean I think
you have to trade and then that files
spoken so Oh Queen takes we were so
happy about it but where will my knight
get tricky
I mean you can yeah you can take and
then go for the g6 break I mean time is
running a little bit like put the 97 97
King up put the King on f7 yeah and now
g6 yes we have to be careful about 96
that's true
cuz I can't take it it's good point I do
have a 6 first that doesn't do much
maybe you can play Knight CA to prepare
it's interesting idea maybe start with
Knights eh and then bring the King to
the Queen side so King e7 yeah King b8
Kings yet we're not I just make sure
there's no scary pawn race did you find
I mean he can't like it's just leader
pause what about putting my team back in
then Bishop 8 I like it sure and take
yeah you can't because your pawns gonna
lose try a6 yeah now's the time and then
take on a4
yeah and now 97 yeah now push probably
don't commit to pushing Bishop eh I
think I think you can I think you can
play knight c6 try knight c6 and now
take and now your king will come to a7
you gotta move quicker you'll gain time
though Oh King a7 very good and now
Bishop d7 to see it win the pawn Oh be
careful be careful that's okay
Bishop c4 there's AB c4 and now bring
your came back to be king b7 you move
you can try a b4 that's the last chance
before
be three and now actually maybe now you
still have there should be five at some
point yeah try this would be five I mean
King be 6 and then Bishop e5 okay this
would be five okay you didn't take a
plate yeah push up on b2 b2 and Bishop
Yates Bishop yet it doesn't work yeah
yeah I think I think it was winning in
the end there it's this one last trick
yeah we're very close
also thanks for the sub gifts you're a
danny wizard gifting five subs to people
I'll read off all the notifications
later okay there's 56 minutes left okay
try and check your notes try and check
it out okay we're back in the line we
like mm-hmm
okay 97 I think whoa honestly I don't
think this works I mean we probably just
take and okay be careful here rook b8
I'm feeling rook a 7 okay having Castle
yeah Castle oh this looks great for you
I mean queen and CSIS Queen c7 and then
bring your Knight to c4 yeah still be
careful a little intimidating the
bishops coming to d3 at some point yeah
a5 not yet I need to get my King to
safety
what if I move the knight slang for my
bishop on e6 mean Bishop d3 I don't
think it's so scary there's no immediate
threat you always have to sex so cuz I'm
bringing my bishop yeah I do like 96
okay um just have to be careful here we
always have Jesus not yet
exactly I mean you have worked eh just
get rid of this rook oh no not rook T
ecause Bishop takes 87 mm-hmm maybe
Knight c4 here like kick the rook but
he's gonna threaten Queen h4 and I get
Quidditch for g6 yeah
wow what a move sorry that's okay I mean
you can play g6 maybe g6 I think you're
still alive okay
and now don't panic just maybe a five
don't panic
famous last words no Queen f7 remember
your rook for defense from afar from a
southern so you just have to defend g6
oh wait sorry you have to watch out for
Bishop takes g6 you're right
so in Queen there any counter play here
I mean you have Bishop f5 I mean that
might just neutralize everything takes
takes and then you're not getting mated
I don't think still so annoying position
but maybe bring the Knight to e4 like
90/60
oh wait watch out for rookie 7 though
yes I like that
the queen of something on I'm King h8 I
have no choice
yes we just want to like simplify into
some end game so we have counter play I
like that yeah I don't see anything
immediate for whites he's pretend he's
protecting that's good I have real
c6c6c6 doesn't do anything ok Queen a
393 sorry no not super scared I mean
maybe put the rook on ca like you're f8
rook is is kind of free right now okay I
mean maybe work t8 actually what is this
move oh wait you you saw might have a
trick of like rook uh rookie it doesn't
work because he makes you wait wait wait
um
rook takes 7 what happens after he takes
yeah yeah what does this move well I
have to you have qing-ge - okay or King
G
then I take on c8 and then I can't block
with the rookie hate but okay that
that's still a fine line for you kingi
eights queen g8 after that I think you
should go for King g8 here King G 8 and
then Queen G for Queen G for then you
take the rook he just takes my queen
then you made on e 1 this is very
important you're threatening mazing one
I'm like ok now you can take the rook
with your king no we might get some end
game where it's night in two pawns versa
King I would try I mean honestly I would
try like kings we made threats if if I
play teenage six can you perpetual me
because I don't think F takes e7 works
those Queen takes f5 and then Queen
takes f4 looks like it should mate maybe
yes it mates so you can't take my rook
unless he promotes with check I mean I'm
thinking King G here and then you take
in you you can still use your knight in
Queen eventually you're gonna trade
Queens and they'll get some okay so you
liking g8 yeah it's gonna go into some
endgame because you have to play like
King f8 and and probably trade yeah and
then now you want to use your night to
win pawns so probably 1993 yeah and then
now Knight f5 win the pawn yep
no takes and now your King has to come
back King up something good no Knight f5
no take or King g7 yeah problem is it's
probably gonna be a draw but you can
still like try I could take that and
play Knight d6 doesn't work okay let's
just try taking right uh yeah go for it
okay this is a good sign because now
you'll have knight c6 blockade probably
97 first and then bring the King to f5
King Jesus I'm no King FC yes now of
critical moments I think you can get
away with go for a knight c6 go for it
and now now take on before with Chuck
yeah
now again needs to calculate a five is
the Tri here and then 96 96 go for it
I'll be four ticks and now push the pawn
we're winning okay okay that was work
good John
good job it takes efforts but okay I'm
starting my game
I appreciate it
smooth okay well we have more London
preparation okay we can up a queen for
some pieces oh yes we're in the same
division has been fine gold okay I have
some insane opening I don't know what's
going on I might just be wasteful your
openings are crazy but yeah the problem
is nasty positions I really appreciate
it I'm trying to think like long term
where the weakness will be I'll
centralize a queen maybe we'll play this
move keep the king in the center and
attacks not working try and provoke some
weakness and black so solid now it's a
problem I want to play queen g6 that
doesn't quite work I also want to save
the bishop
I might just resign yeah it's it's not
easy no I agree but I have queen and
night like there's cases where it might
underestimate Queen and Knights
appreciate it oh yeah those is an
interesting opening of it it was it was
okay Komodo 18 rights yep it's okay try
and get something similar okay this is
what I like to see this is my my prep
line had to so many times before so I'm
trying to remember the move here because
it's actually playing like one of the
main lines also oh we almost have an
hour okay that's that's still good shape
shape to view oh no sorry half an hour
because we started at 2:15 we're we have
47 minutes left right when does it end I
think 8 o'clock central so 6 o'clock
your time okay perfect okay yeah that's
playing this line better unfortunately
I'm still going for the throat komodo
has a throat right 93 mmm let's take
here mmm this is unfortunate it's not
plundering in this line anymore
wait I have to trick I've rook takes b7
and then oh that doesn't work or does it
takes takes it might work I think oh but
blocks I thought the night was pinned
but I forgot the rook is a rugby a good
point it's like the opera game except
not working
this is close it's so close to winning
but it's not winning let's keep the
attack uh-huh
this is really unfortunate coming here
no it starts killing me it's gonna maybe
okay it's okay I'm gonna try and still
get it an opening preparation yeah I
know what I did wrong there I didn't I
Castle too soon let's play again
18 with white okay okay yeah so okay
similar a bit difference bits from your
Danny wizard thanks for the bits okay so
we have another line yeah okay this is
what I like to see very solid in these
King side attack lines no I've had this
position wait no I'm not just winning
six looks disgusting yeah it doesn't win
immediately but it's so pleasant for
most people night of three yeah I should
probably castle yeah and then if he
plays efore that's true
maybe Bishop its defending and attacking
me nice you wrote you could play rookie
one after E 4 and then sack on e4 and
then pray yeah and then pray if we have
nothing else cousin I can't move it
seems so close to working ok I'm gonna
go for this line ok I'm looking at the
variation with whoa bits Knight g5 takes
and then takes promised Queen G so Queen
g7 doesn't work let's go for this if it
doesn't work it doesn't work
mmm that's so close Knight g5 all Queen
Bishop e3 yeah let's counter play coming
okay still play this position okay
there's still like some attack it's kind
of dying out yeah yeah it's it's still
winnable and even if we don't check mate
we can get the pawn back and try to
trick it in an endgame that's very true
just trying to figure out how I get a
rook to the G file maybe start with
rogue h4 and now rook h1 now maybe it's
sneaking with Queen D 1 also Knight g5
ideas no chief oh no chief okay I always
play king bee 100k been fine gold is
wrong in that position smooth back first
computer kimono 18 okay no I like the
position I think I just have to slow
down especially if we get this line
again yeah we're gonna get the same line
again and stuck on 16 great in our
division we're killing it okay try and
kill it even more yeah let's try to kill
overall not just okay I'm still using my
H file like each pile maybe played a bit
slower than the extreme kill yeah f
words always annoying but if you just
move your Bishop Makdissi - yeah this is
more comfortable than last game because
I Kings a bit safer I still have the
double up okay this is where we have to
start thinking like what what does a
plant right carry through with attack I
mean I could slow play
there's g4 g5 ideas kind of looks nice
I'm feeling King be one King a one like
at the King say first alright okay
that's a very good save three is to
weakening I agree
g6 is a week now so maybe there's ideas
of like rook h2 + 9 h4 that's
interesting but you need to take care of
the f2 pawn
yeah also ideas of rookie one I guess
let's try to e4 and winning f2 so maybe
you work f1 it's ugly but it's ugly but
it holds and windows ok we'll see what
he does this is very ugly I want to move
to d4 of it loses a pawn great let's
move bad night not the prettiest of
positions no it's not I have F 3 maybe f
3 I was looking at it looks interesting
yeah ok so it's very overextended now
yes actually it's a promise g3 is kind
of hanging so maybe fo Brookes attacked
too
so Rick f4 yeah Rica for and then if he
takes the bishop take with the Queen and
attack she's sick ok that's why you
didn't do it Thanks that's a very
strange position what about 93 now can
try that 93 but he takes with the bishop
we take with the Queen
oh yeah g6 is weak in the end ok so he
take it that's good mmm I'm not liking
the position like let's just play yeah
playing strong it's still playable like
e3 is very tender
I don't we need 3 somehow but the pieces
are just so clumsy you won no he's not
gonna take it that's not a bad idea
I'll put the rook on d3 ok so it's
really holding on holding night before
night before d5 is gonna fall right he
can protect I have c4 c4 it just winds
upon I believe nice we take back with
the Poli call me with pawn very good
yeah okay so now we're we're kind of out
playing it knight c6 ideas there's also
night c2 just kind of safety maybe d6
first and then mean g6 with d7 ideas ok
I like it
maybe g4
interesting the reckoning but then
there's h4 yes then we give him a pass
punt
I mean queen f1 you can't actually pushy
- it's true but it looks it feels wrong
it feels very wrong yeah I'm looking for
counterplay I mean knight c6 you thought
of but but after he gets rook takes you
to them I mean I'm actually looking at
d7 rook takes G 2 and then knight c6 and
then if you please ripped you on you
block with the rook yeah that's
interesting actually
I'm gonna try it okay thanks all right
Wow so just gave away a rook this is
great oh wait wait wait wait we might
have missed something
oh it's still very tricky King C - C -
it looks like we have to try oh my gosh
I'm just losing the Queen there might be
some weird counter play in the end like
97 yeah I mean we should try I guess
maybe there's no Queen yet okay yeah
yeah this is probably reasonable okay
yeah everything oh it was really close I
mean necessarily maybe you did play the
right ones
yeah I mean I'm liking the positions for
the most parts it's just putting up like
more resistance and we won't get a good
position but takes more position to
converts so I'm waiting okay another
London I have this line again so I play
this minute we're getting closer
okay so Bishop d7 I think a new move
I've 93 it's also bishop c7 interesting
but I'm gonna let you take the expert
yeah
positions I'll let you know when
something to look for I think I'm just
gonna castle okay
so tricky let's go for Queen a for all
right yeah nice Wow what does this move
its final moves that are hard to see I
think I'll take on d5 first now my Queen
can come back so I can take on c6 that
actually looks nice takes on c6 and then
Queen d4 keep Queens on the board okay
yeah still behind in development okay so
he's being very materialistic this is
what we want as the kings in the center
rook takes c6 is an idea also there's
ideas of trapping the Queen whoa just
gifting subs but I'm going to stay
focused yes I'll thank them for you
thank you just calm for the 575 is a
free night never run I mean Knight c5 is
interesting Knight c5 I don't want to
lose a bishop I have to lose something
here looking for moves let's see five
ticks ticks yeah I know this is very
difficult I could play Knight 92 looks
so passive
maybe Knight fd2 Knight f d2 is looks
playable actually we have ideas of rook
a one oh he didn't even take the bishop
okay okay one there's Queen c2 so it's
slippery 94 too many discovery attacks
maybe Bishop g5 I'm really looking for
ways to trap the Queen 55 and he plays
Knight of 6 yeah everything is protected
or traditionally Queen h4 Bishop g5
essentially so that's good move
I like messing up his bone structure
here can we'll move back again in b6
potentially the b6 is kind of weak now
we can invade we can attack you six but
there's Bishop d5 mm-hmm car will be 20
Wow
well there's still one more final boss I
think this it's kind of falling apart
here unfortunately that's a beautiful
I'm looking for moves but I'm not seeing
them move okay so it didn't take the
night that's being friendly it's still
not easy
rook a one rook c1 it's just kind of
playing around with me rook a1 it's just
you don't have any follow up after that
yeah it's such a difficult position I'm
gonna resign it's new game okay I didn't
like the opening okay I'm gonna play
again level 18 checking on Ben he's
still at 16 okay good and planet chess
club is at 15 so this is good okay oh he
gotta be 20 okay it started as black for
some reason cause my kid okay we're
gonna refresh that okay would be whites
okay deep breath we still have half hour
left
yep that's very doable as long do you
know how the European division did for
our section because I know Simon
Williams also got to some relatively
high level are we competing with art
with the Europeans yeah there's an
overall first price check does anybody
know how far the European team in 2600
that's you I'm really liking this
position again
okay like look at this oh okay I'm still
kind of alive I don't really want to
trade into an endgame I kind of have to
though well it's not going into an
endgame
can I go for a night h3 try an attack
okay it's being weird let's play with t1
maybe Bishop e2
okay so we're tied with Bigfoot in
ginger gym so okay that's very good
that's very good okay
bong bong cloud style can you - and now
it's time to go for the kill queen h6
ideas Queen age six Queen take C - D -
looks pleasant you three is probably a
good sign
Knight g5 so we have to watch out for
Queen takes CQ so Knight g5 I mean it's
so close to winning king of five this is
where we calculate Knight g5 Queen takes
c2 kim taek's III then there's pawn
takes h5 and then there's rook to e3 hmm
I mean it looks like it works by g5
I mean do you see any way for black to
defend each seven other than like trying
to spy check us no he doesn't have space
Knight f6 we just take me okay I like it
rook d3 now okay this is very good so
you know we don't celebrate prematurely
but we celebrates after we take every
yes next game okay do this h-file like
once the file opens and you attack the
king it's so fun you just have to not
let the compensation okay so it's
playing positionally doing do your
French things like Bishop c5 you take I
do my French thing I can play Queen b6
and trade that's not a bad idea actually
like I would support an endgame before
five after that takes before this rook
takes a for unfortunately I mean I could
push b4 I like before just gain space
then Queen
queer seven yeah your point Kevin Queen
a seven you keep the Queen on the same
diagonal yes probably you have to play
rook repeats kind of white might be
winning upon here unfortunately
what about b3 b3 actually looks really
interesting
and now Bishop d7 things are actually
protected yeah okay there should be
seven when you have the chance you want
to castle but forty okay this is getting
scary maybe nightie for an ID a six is
also kind of weak what about ninety four
night a four is also a nine a for the
problem is Queen takes a seven takes a
seven or takes a four and then rook c8
in the end oh but then c1 Queen and then
that might actually be playable for
Queen takes me eight Queen XA 7 takes a
7 I mean there's where ticks c2 c1 after
that I mean there's not much else to do
actually like you might have to and
there's also an IE 4 but and then yeah I
just think we're gonna get the B to pawn
with my knight would get trapped or no
maybe not it yeah you can go for it cuz
you wanna okay rook takes a seven are we
sure we don't play c1 first because then
V 2 is no you want to keep your pond in
the line where you Queen yeah and then
you play like kingi 7 and then B 3 and
then rook b8 play I think and maybe now
rook it's yeah you want to win something
yep rook aah yeah right yeah okay that's
probably good news
takes yeah that's a very good move I
think you probably resigned and starting
again okay yeah I got messy like we
really want to avoid the messy positions
and we win everything overall so it
would be nice so we have half hour
yep do your thing okay that's okay
there should be something yeah that's
not a bad move Queen takes critics
it's very positional like fine structure
like castle here
he doesn't have enough to sag yeah like
castling Bishop e7 whoa or he thinks he
does ah it's on a sack she wins
the night right she's not a pun yeah and
you could try and fight I mean honestly
I'd say resign start a new game because
we agree this was 18 yeah okay we are go
away be nice if the castles queenside
like we're waiting I mean actually it
might it might do it same line nice I
like what I see
Queen b6 sure Queen b6 nice okay so this
is my stuff okay
so we want a castle and get the rook to
see it should be seven sure yeah and now
Castle castling good White has very
little attack no Brooke I've see it
maybe to start yeah okay and now a five
a five good um maybe like before you
have to be a little careful about him
Jean yeah you have not afraid if needed
I think you're still solid though it's
just scary like f6 become okay so before
or a four I ask like why can't you just
like take on a five
a point and then get the night to e6
maybe there's not mean that's still
tricky position bless you thank you okay
thank you
maybe I mean night what about Queenie
six no the problem is the night will
come to d4 eventually yeah I mean
there's night f8 you give away the pawn
but you get the knight to e6
I kind of like that 96 96 you're
fighting for the d4 square that's a very
strange move weird I mean you're
probably taken and start focusing on the
C file yeah let's do that now Queen c5 I
was thinking rook c4 like rook c4 k c8
interesting you can't take D actually he
can again so maybe rook c5 rook c5 over
can't be removed you build up well he's
gonna start attacking on f7 that's true
you could plank like Queens like rook c5
Queen c7 rook c8 okay let's play I take
here I have to take now probably Rick
see it there's also rook e8 cuz east six
could be annoying c6 you can probably
take and play King h8 alright so we want
to try you could also play Bishop maybe
Bishop to you CA to e6 yeah keep it like
solid I like that I like that too any
tricks you know bishop
oh there should be six he's gonna take
so the pawn like both ones Oh actually
no you can you can play Bishop e6 he
can't take on d5 cuz you oh wait you can
my dad I mean you can you can win the e5
pawn and some of our some
you have to be careful about three so
maybe I just take the bishop here you
have to be very careful with back rank
yeah and then I'll play rook e8 after
mmm there's lucky one or well I think I
have to take the bishop right because we
don't want him to take on e6 e7 is also
a threat rook a c8 actually yeah maybe
you take the bishop and play rook e8
you're gonna play rook d7 and then you
take on e5 okay so we have an endgame
this is not a bad thing
I'll take with the pawn oh sure yeah and
we need eyes okay Queenie five okay I
can just put my rook back in Queen d7 is
coming but your pawns defended I believe
back sure okay now maybe be fresh yeah
that's very scary position well he needs
space Queen c7 yeah okay now you want to
play like positional build up rookie 77
Riki seven double up on like you're
getting ready six that's true I say
rookie 7 I would just push me 5 here no
not yet you're sure you don't like rook
cd8 first getting on those and file or
brookie d8 like try and chase the Queen
away from defending C - hmm interesting
we lose a pawn and then put my okay I
like this now even like King h8 like oh
I can't take anything King h8 scheme
safety no yeah Brooke d6 looks fine
protect and maybe even like rook c6 like
put a lot of pressure at work c6 is an
attack anything he takes
six so that's true okay so you have to
move faster but okay there's a very
clear plan
defendi six with Queen d7 and then get
ready to play rook b8 and a4 right
though maybe I think this okay a for a
for ya you want to break down yeah okay
this is good sign um three maybe you
leave the tension like play rook aid
first you gotta move faster
rook a8 okay and now rook da six and now
h g 6g sixty six sixty pigs that's true
h6 Kim G and now Queen f7 I that's fine
Oh take on a - okay okay take on a for
Brooke b6 - B - that's okay just play
click quick moves safe moves in gain
time trade Queens Queenie six very good
take now push the e pawn rook c6
blockade yeah yeah bring the King in
maybe double up on e-file now G for a g5
in king g6 to h5
mmm it's really close yeah resign
close game we were breaking through at
some points just time goddess but very
good game I mean it's it's clearly
beautiful we just have to like it is
yeah sorry matrix and posting lines in
the check qualified oh they don't care
about moves in check that's hilarious
cool but still don't post them easier so
it's easier okay okay do your thing how
are we doing okay on time yeah we have
20 or 19 minutes left what the [ __ ] okay
oh oh there's a cool line here there's a
very interesting line here play a queen
be six to start okay Bishop e7 then f6
take can you taking we're on e5 go for
it yeah I like it and then taking then
take with pawn probably like open open
lines open that file yeah Cassidy for
first castling looks good thread me for
okay
and now maybe still like I mean there's
Mike yeah we probably before he takes d4
is also interesting because it opens up
my bishop
I'm liking efore followed by you like
ideas of a five okay yeah okay this is
looking very very good but we want to be
precise still I agree so Knight of 6 he
takes on e5 not good yeah the problem is
White's gonna control the d4 square so
we want to look for like the right
target yeah if Knight f6 we have here's
h3 okay
it's queen g6 ideas we can remove the
Queen actually so that if he takes we
can take that but it doesn't do much but
at least give the bishop up I mean I'm
thinking actually
taking on d4 and playing Bishop c5 try
and open things up you really want to
get to have to we have to play Queen e6
yeah and then the Queen's vulnerable
like the Queen's not a good luck either
okay this is kind of 95 - I don't think
interesting though d5 is under pressure
because it's yeah your knight needs to
find a good square I mean your Bishop
Knight f6 if you takes I take with the
Queen and then if he takes on you do it
do it 906 I like it okay he didn't even
take and now you might have to build up
like Bishop I mean Bishop e6 or Bishop
d7
rooks rook c8 yeah okay let's just keep
putting pressure on the other sides what
else might wants to come to f4 somehow
yeah I mean it's a weird idea that maybe
King G King h8 9897
it's slow is there anything faster I'm
looking I mean there's Queen d6 with
idea of Bishop d6 to c7 like threatening
alongside like try that straighter cuz
White's kind of stuck yeah no probably
Bishop b6 yeah okay so take with
probably pawn I'm gonna keep my Queen
here
yeah mm-hmm okay no I mean you brought
me yeah Bishop d7 I like let's first
keep it on how can I use my rooks better
here okay well III doesn't do anything
that I have rook cd8 I mean it opens
another file which yeah the thing is
we're down the piece and it's it's not
gonna get mated what about rook to e8 no
he's just a block what about Queen a3
yeah Queen a3 is interesting try Queen
a3 and rook c3 ideas
okay take the Knights because this is a
very valuable piece now you have ideas
of maybe d4 first yeah we have to be
precise here we're also getting a long
time d4 he just takes it oh never mind
but he doesn't take with check which I
guess well it's protected now so I think
roots III Brooks III okay can go for it
okay um the Kings are just gonna sit on
each - so maybe rook Jesus but then the
knight is stuck - that's true
and I could bring in the other look
after know what maybe you just rook at
c8 doesn't have any tricks I just want
like rook F c8 idea of a queen d6 cuz
Queen d6 I think doesn't work sorry
where were you saying
Queen d6 to g3 it's not a mate I'm not
sure Queen d6
there's also rook g3 first rook g3 King
H 2 then Queen d6 I like that better
the prom is Queen e5 I have to try
something yeah but we could play rook g5
mmm things are kind of or you could take
the Queen and play always and then play
97 he attacks it okay I think we want to
play another game is there anything you
still think we should try here 97 you
can try it yeah that's close one
I like the opening it was good try
aggressive position yeah okay it's hard
it's hard being down a piece so we have
14 minutes left okay
so 14 minutes that's not terrible
okay I'm challenging him I'm waiting
yeah that's right you six good
if some lines are more force yeah I mean
this is your bread and butter okay okay
this is very good to see okay so b5 yeah
okay this is also good to see so you
remember that game where you play like
97 to b6 yes
try doing right now I mean yeah there's
a bunch of moves to start with you can
play Queen c7 first stay flexible
okay White's going insane but again we
have to be careful mm-hmm I mean maybe
just take on a foreign Castle kinda like
it
where's this night going I also have
Bishop e7 bishops these six ideas or
Queen c6 honestly I like castling like
yet you're looking to play okay
maybe night I think he's doing f5 so
maybe 96 on these shirts and you have a
5 ideas right away yeah trying to
disable I know I like a 5 like why not
now get rid of this B pawn queen will
come in I mean there's all these ideas
now checking but okay we want to be
controlled do when do I take because if
I move my Bishop to d7 I'm bringing the
rook to b8 yeah I mean honestly I was
thinking 97 like try and trade off
Knights bit easier to play oh and then I
get played Bishop basics okay now be
careful because White has some
initiative but Queen a7 probably not
today okay now we don't want to trade
Queens probably Queen a for it at that
for pond and defend the night yep that's
good move maybe okay five is looking at
Queen f1 so it's good Queen B five okay
do you have Knight see Knight to b6
followed by like night c4 ideas well
might be 60 is gonna play rook d7
then you have queen f1 followed by
Knight c4 aha okay still like Oh be
careful though because Queen uh honours
anymore that's so close to winning I
mean you have actually a queen f1 rook
d1 and then Queen f2 defending your
knight and you just want to find he
could try to perpetual it
yeah worst-case scenario you bring your
queen to e3 I think
okay so Queen f2 okay this is what we
like to see well no my queen is almost
you complain that Queen h4 you all you
want to do is keep Queens on the board
and play Knight c4 so I think Queen each
core is worth it Queen d8 yeah your
queen just like I know be careful cuz
rook takes c4 good point I didn't play
it maybe Queen be a first
yeah Queen B it works I like it she has
rupees seven which it's okay cuz Queen
d8 oh then he has Queen takes no that's
okay because we win the exchange Queen
takes e4 it doesn't work for whites oh
right okay so we're dudes
okay and now he's threatening rippy
force so now we play like queen east
seven seven yeah okay 28 yeah it's ugly
but okay we're so close I think this is
the moment to try it and Queenie for we
also there's also a simple line 93 93
these also has might be one I say gopher
yeah gopher this week okay okay Queen a
for I quit before there's Knight takes
e4 so it's not gonna I don't think it's
gonna lose immediately we still have
nine minutes left okay but time is still
ticking so I could also
and then bring an or when do we want to
do night yeast so don't think we want to
trade nights but we might have to I mean
honestly the position after Queen a4
looks really good
yeah we take the rook and then take back
but I don't know something better
okay now we want to somehow prepare them
so you know there's this very nice idea
of rook c8 play h6 at some point then
lift the rook to be 5 or Queen c7 here
should be winning and now okay and then
Queen b7 honestly I like Queen b7 first
Queen b7 and if he blocks it if Queen b3
then we have Queen a7 or wait and then
he plays King a1 and Queen a - it's true
it's so close Rippy Rippy and Queen b7
maybe you could try King over well yeah
cuz how go for it cuz time is ticking so
rope b8 Network the eights and then
Queen B something no rook d7 there's
Queen aides sorry Queen B so Queen b7
there's gonna be Queen b3 and then then
we I think we have Queen a8 check Queen
takes Queen eight and then back to c6
wait yeah Queen c6 now yes and now we're
gates yes okay okay now now gain time
like still become push pawns like don't
don't like Mouse slip and make a clip of
yourself be careful be very careful here
be very very careful okay I can take and
then put my Queen on e6 and stop the
pond okay good or a queen d6 check be
careful okay and now keep Queen c7 the
pawns okay now yeah King d3 king d3 just
keep it simple
okay push pawn I mean you have enough
time just don't still need yeah yeah
King D to make a queen no wait
ticks ticks upon just make me do
anything
very good oh I have to play a motive 19
wait okay very good
good job
that was beautiful by the way this Queen
eight was move was key to get to c6
watching you okay we have London theory
again this line is so annoying
what's the move here I think it's just
52 now a3 just trying to remember my
computer lines no probably the smooth
Bishop c4 or is it c4 maybe it's c4
first
okay let's my dear so weird though c4
takes yes does okay I'm trying this is
almost our last drink I just yeah we
have I'm so close to trapping the Queen
yeah it's an age I have this Oh this
idea 92 and then they should at c4 see
Oh night see one
oh and I see one Queen a one right and
then I can't get um Bishop c4
interesting at all mean c-4 actually
looks Pleasant c4 a foregrip g3
well it's something it's a donation I
don't know how much though let's take
three dollars for gents double O nine
thank you for donating to Eric I'm
really thinking who Queens getting out
it's still kind of stuck though maybe I
take here I got out okay I mean the
resign and start a new game minutes but
we're in clear first and in both
divisions right or out of both divisions
I think okay people said the highest was
number 18 in Europe but if anyone else
has the stuff that would be amazing but
what about Ben Feingold
yeah we're winning both Oh Ben Feingold
is like level 17 okay okay going long
going for the pot sir attack I just want
to win immediately like H oh the bishop
defense from afar
so maybe g4 is going all out here well
you have to because you have four
minutes yeah that's annoying move B to I
have to do this this is very ugly King
do you two there's Nathan yeah well he
takes okay yeah I got me okay let's try
again until another nineteen be white
all right so this could be the last game
gonna try and like be slow here again
it's going for this line which is what I
like to see Celeste game it didn't
players yeah this is a line I know pass
all the okay let's finish it off and
some style I mean I could take a draw
like repetition maybe Bishop c4 Bishop
c4 I guess takes and now I have a bishop
pair okay it's going to be very
materialistic I'm Gavin ting all my
pawns and now I'm down like four pawns
but I have bishops and let's try mmm
problem is it's not going to like lose
immediately played Bishop d2 but it'll
play very quickly yeah I gamma to the
Knights on accident Bishop g5 okay I
resign so we have time for what this is
probably the last yeah we have another
two minutes but good job like this is
this is a great teamwork performance
your French defense I never thought I
said I would say this but like the
French defense was amazing I feel I feel
so inspired to play the French now like
these monster attacks okay after defense
okay I'm still going for like these
scenarios where it gets a bit too feisty
don't wanna get mated though I might be
getting mated mmm
this is not good let's resign and play
one more game one more game
one more white okay this is probably the
last game so yeah I'll try my best
of course you have been we'll get a good
last position now it so done is on 17
okay interesting okay so it's playing
this line again so I we went through all
of this
um no Rick see bullet Eric okay now I
have to chop the Queen somehow no I
chopped the Queen maybe let's do this
first and then I'll win the pawn and
then I'll win this guy came safety being
safety yep okay so the the Kings in the
center so we have to prevent him from
castle oh never mind
let's play this going for the attack now
I'm looking for some way to just
sacrifice let's do those things like
that it doesn't work though
I'm just I just want to sell a grace
it's it's 8 o'clock right it's 6:00 okay
I'm gonna try it okay I resign
actually let's get me I'll give it
satisfaction yeah there you go
whoa good job
do we be one both like our section and
the overall section I don't think we won
overall or like within our division
yeah within our division we surpassed
that you so that's what matters for
prize money right I think so let me see
what it says so we got a bonus prize of
$500 that was great for the nine Queens
yeah yeah and then for regional prizing
we did win a thousand two hundred nice
and then we win a thousand for our
overall prize too because we we won our
region and we won overall in 2020 so did
we just clean up like we want all the
prizes except the castling oh this is
very good so no you did so well you're
like your french openings oh it was a
team effort though like whole London
worked out people London in the French
I'm gonna end the French comodo can't
handle it